revenge revenge revenge
let us kill let us cut to pieces let us
swim in blood up to our knees
revenge revenge revenge
let us wipe the stain from our clothes
that is a song
taught to turkish school children
as reported by the u.s consulate in
february of 1915
and this is jocko podcast number 280
with echo charles and me jocko willink
good evening echo good evening
also joining us tonight is daryl cooper
good evening
and the blood spread step by step
[Music]
from ankara to distant cities towns and
villages
at the end of august 1915 a girl barely
13 years old
told me of the following to which she
had been an
eyewitness in which she only by some
miracle
had survived in mid-august all armenian
males from 12 to 80 were arrested
taken out of town and killed by
unheard of tortures next it was the turn
of the girls and women on august 20th
all the armenian women girls and small
boys
were taken out into more than 70
carriages and brought to a valley by a
bridge an hour and a half away
following these carriages from the town
was an armed
mob of turks each of whom on the way
chose a sheep or lamb to slaughter
when they reached the area under the
bridge police and soldiers
having joined the savage mob set upon
these poor defenseless women
mothers brides virgins and children
just as spring trees are cut down with
bill
hooked hedge knives the bloodthirsty mob
attacked this group more than 400
with axes hatchets shovels and
pitchforks
hacking off their appendages noses ears
legs arms fingers shoulders they dash
the little children against the rocks
before their eyes of their mothers while
shouting
allah allah the screams of the mothers
and virgins and little children echoed
across the valley in the surrounding
rocky
hills and caves the children screamed
mayrig
mayrig mother mother
help us please
but the mob indifferent
continued to rip apart the bodies so
that even the stones cried out
finally after four to five hours of
carnage and plunder
knight's black blanket covered this
scene of blood
which would stir the envy of wild
animals
with the fall of night the turkish mob
police and police soldiers returned to
town with their bundles
of loot whatever they had left
[Music]
hyenas wolves jackals and other
scavengers came off to finish
the precipices of the valley were strewn
with corpses
naked or half naked
it was a scene beyond all human
imagination
now and then in the darkness of the
night the moans and groans of the badly
wounded
then the raspy drone of those giving up
the ghost could be heard
after midnight in the thick darkness a
refreshing
dew began to fall
and behold a slightly wounded numb
little girl
invigorated by the dew woke up
half alive she began to rove in search
of her mother
and two sisters
in vain she called them by name but alas
they were gone to eternal sleep
at last she found their crushed bodies
which had fallen one beside the other
in shock the girl began to shake and sob
uncontrollably
her teeth chattering she did not move
from that spot until morning
as if the bodies of her mother and her
older sisters compelled her to stay
there
at dawn a few of the kurdish cowed
cow herders crossing the bridge in the
vicinity of this carnage
saw one of the corpses moving in the
distance
they approached her took pity on her and
brought her home to their father's care
being an anti-turk muslim kurdish he
secretly turned her over to his longtime
friend
it was with the arrival of this little
girl in the town where we were staying
that for the first time
we became aware of the extent of the
killing being carried out
around us without a sound
or whisper
and that is an excerpt from a
book called armenian golgotha
by a man named grigoris
balakian and gregorius was born in
1875 in tokat part of the
ottoman empire educated in germany
eventually became a celibate priest
in the armenian apostolic church
and he was one of the countless
armenians who suffered through
the armenian genocide
though he was one of the lucky ones that
actually survived and he wrote
a book about his experiences and like i
said the book is called
armenian golgotha and if you don't know
what golgotha is golgotha is the name of
the hill
where jesus was crucified
and this event is
where the armenians as a people were
crucified
and where as individuals for many a mere
crucifixion would have been merciful
but before we jump into more of the book
i wanted to um
go into some of the background since
this event
is not as well known as some other
genocides
so daryl let's talk about how we got
here and and
what are some of the similarities and
differences about what happened to the
armenians
and what has happened to some other
persecuted groups in the past what's the
background here
there's some people that called the 20th
century the century of genocide
you look all throughout history and
there's no shortage of mass killing
of human beings by other human beings
in fact if you go all the way back back
to like our tribal times
warfare by genocide was pretty typical
you had nomadic tribes
they didn't have prisons they didn't
have jails they didn't have pow camps or
anything like that if you conquered
another tribe
their men were going to be a problem and
you didn't have anywhere to keep them
and so the standard operating procedure
was you just
took them out took the women that were
willing to sort of
i guess get over it back to your tribe
with you back raise the children as your
own
um almost like social mammals you know
like lions
you know somebody comes in kills the
male lion and now takes over the pride
as time developed you started to get
a sort of systematic civilized level of
mass killing
at scale that had never been possible in
tribal times that you could only really
uh you you could only manage with the
same sort of administration and
organization
that allowed you to do things like build
pyramids and all the great
uh wonders of civilization right and
when you get up to the modern times
you get something that's even a little
bit more
well a little bit different than that if
we think back to say the romans
and what they did to carthage carthage
had been giving rome problems
hannibal had been rampaging around the
italian peninsula defeating their armies
and when they finally got the drop on
the carthaginians they said
salt the earth we're not dealing with
this anymore
eliminate that threat for good and they
did
when caesar went up to gaul you know
rome had been sacked by gaul before it
was a traumatic event in roman history
and so when caesar went up there and
ended that threat
thoroughly um you could think of it in a
similar way
it was attached to conquest and that's
what you kind of saw throughout history
when you get up to the 20th century you
see something in a way that's
different and much darker i think which
is
you have established firmly established
states
annihilating internal uh internal
enemies according to the state
attacking captive populations over which
they have complete power in control
you're not going in and eliminating a
threat that exists over the horizon
making sure that it never returns
you know you're going into a prison
where everybody's kept in a cell
and one by one these unarmed people
you're simply murdering all of these
people over
whom you have complete power
when you think of what happened to the
armenians when you think of what
happened to the ukrainians under stalin
to the jews under hitler
these are the kinds of things you see
this is a disarmed captive population
that
is not a threat and
there's no way out and that's really the
key characteristic of these events
is if you go to those people and you saw
this you saw this with the jews in
germany you saw this with the ukrainians
you saw this with
the armenians absolutely at the
beginning of the first world war is a
huge part of the population including
the leadership
is really actively asking the question
what can we do
what can we do like what is it at the
beginning of the first world war the
armenians were flying turkish flags
tens of thousands of them went right
away and joined the turkish military
because they knew they had a history
with the turks they'd had problems
before
20 years back we'll talk about in a
second 300 000 or so of them got
massacred
and they knew in the first world war
detention was going to be high and the
stress was going to be high
so what can we do to show our loyalty to
the empire to show that we're down for
the cause
and the answer is there's nothing you
can do there's nothing you can do
you're all going to be wiped out and
there's nothing you can do
and it's the ultimate horror movie to
have your state
turn on you like that you know
and um it's it's interesting that you
say
uh that the armenian genocide isn't that
well known which is very very true
um because it really is kind of the
archetypal act of genocide in the 20th
century it was really like the first one
early in the century that set the tone
for all of the ones that came afterwards
and it was one of the most thorough and
complete and systematic
and intentional genocides that we have
any record of
um that erasure of genocide
is something that you also see
throughout history i mean how many
countless peoples
have been genocided throughout history
that we don't even know their names
we'll never know their names and maybe
we even celebrate the history of the
people who did it
as a glorious civilization and we will
never know the names of the countless
people that they completely wiped out
it's something that uh we don't like to
mention
uh or talk about or admit but the fact
is that
uh more often than not if you look
historically speaking genocide
tends to work not only are a lot of
genocides
physically successful but
more more often than we would we would
really prefer the one that does it
ends up getting away with it and getting
getting the message put out to the rest
of the world and people in the future
who who might think of doing something
similar that this is an
option in fact when adolf hitler was
contemplating his final solution for the
jewish question in eastern europe
he asked his commanding generals who
today remembers the armenians
because the truth was nobody did yeah
it's uh also interesting that in world
war one there was plenty of jews that
fought
for for germany well over a hundred
thousand yeah
valiantly by the way um
hitler's life was saved by a jewish
soldier um he he received
his iron cross from a jewish uh superior
officer
um so so as
we as we push through this let's talk
about like the relationship a little bit
of the turkish people and the armenians
in
in terms of how do we end up here you
know i i mentioned that it is really the
archetypal genocide of the 20th century
and i don't just say that because of the
methods that were used
in fact the methods that were used in a
way were kind of anachronistic and
unique to the turkish empire
it was archetypal of the 20th century
genocides
because of what what you just asked
because of the specific relationship
between
the dominant majority group and this
particular armenian
minority you know the turks the ottoman
empire is a it's a uh
it's a strange thing to study when you
get up to the late period in the 20th
century because
you know like if you ever asked yourself
like what would it have been like
if like the golden horde right or the
mongols or something had just they had
managed to establish themselves
somewhere
um on the on the outskirts of europe and
they lasted and you get all the way up
to the 20th century
and they're still there and they have an
advanced civilization now you know the
genghis khan's like descendants like
they now have
control they have a big battle fleet you
know they've got modern weaponry i mean
it's a big
glorious civilization constantinople you
know at the
when the first world war kicked off
you're talking about one of
one of the most sophisticated glorious
cities in the world
and um the ottoman empire gives you some
idea of what it would be like if the
golden horde survived into the 20th
century
this is um you know the the their turkic
peoples who came in as step
warriors and conquered the byzantine
empire and took over you know all of
north africa uh
basically everything between morocco and
persia and then down into egypt
and these and so what you end up in a
situation like this is you
end up with like a warlike
people right that's what they are what
they respect
is war and being warriors and that sort
of becomes the
the most respected class of people oh
yeah
yeah the um the idea in in the major
islamic empires was always that
we the majority population the people in
the commanding position
of this society we fight the wars and
everybody else the christian and jewish
minorities for example they pay for the
wars
and that's how it works we're a warrior
people i mean these are step
warriors who came and built up a big
civilization
and they kept a lot of that character
even as they went forward even as they
were wearing
suits and ties and uh you know going to
to
to big security conferences and
international conferences in europe and
the united states they still had that
in them this was a warrior people from
an age where
it was perfectly typical to offer your
enemies
the the option to either unconditionally
surrender or be massacred totally
it was the mode of warfare on the step
when they were conquering civilizations
it's how the ottoman empire got to where
it was
and so as you as you move into modernity
you have this society there that up
until
the early 1800s still had its entire
bureaucracy
governmental bureaucracy and most of its
military
like its serious military officers were
still people who had been taken as
slaves
as children and brought back for that
specific function they would go up to
the balkans they would go up into the
caucasus area
because according to islamic law you
can't enslave fellow muslims and so they
would go into christian areas
and just go into a village and say we
need 10 people we can do we need 10 male
children we can do this the easy way or
the hard way
and they would do it the easy way
because they knew what the hard way
looked like under the ottoman empire and
it was
no prettier than it got in the 20th
century
and by the time they got up to um
the early 1800s this group of
bureaucrats and soldiers called the
janissaries
these were slave soldiers and
bureaucrats who more or less ran
the important functions of the empire by
the time you got up to the late 17th
early 1800s they were in fact running
large
sections of the economy they held
you know all the most important
government positions and they were
getting into this kind of strange place
with the ruling
elites the ruling turkish elites where
the turks are overall in charge
but this other group of people who are
muslim they were born christian children
but they were converted as children to
muslims but
that this identifiable group of people
who has their own sense of themselves as
an identifiable group these janissaries
that they have a tremendous amount of
influence in power that they're really
the ones running the empire
and it got to a point where the
government the turkish government
decided they couldn't trust these people
anymore and they locked them all in
their barracks one night and they burned
them all to death
when they felt that this small minority
group was accruing too much
power and middle management where they
kind of maybe probably could run the
empire without the turks if they really
wanted to their response was to wipe all
of those people out overnight
and that's what they did and it's known
in ottoman history it was known in
ottoman history as the auspicious event
this is like a bunch of
let's say ufc fighters that are training
hard
they they fight they they punch each
other they kick each other they wrestle
and and their agents and promoters
are out there doing the you know the
work that they look down upon hey i'm
not some promoter i'm not some agent i'm
out
i'm a fighter and then one day they look
up and they go wait a second why is that
guy driving a freaking
uh a mercedes s-class and i'm over here
in a toyota camry
and they get together and say we're not
gonna do this anymore
that yeah that's one way to look at it i
mean well and so in the thing that's so
interesting about it right is if you
look at what happened to the overseas
chinese population in indonesia in the
1960s
if you look at what happened to the east
indian population
of east africa in the 1970s under like
idiyamine and
and some others if you look at what
happened to the jews in europe
if there are you can go down the line
the people who are targeted are almost
inevitably
this similar group of people right if
you look in europe with the jews
for a long time you know we were under a
feudal system the people who were in
charge the elites in a feudal system
they own all the land the the
source of wealth in society is from the
land the majority of the local european
population are all peasants or maybe
small artisans
uh but then you have this group move in
you have the jews move in
and the jews have been living in cities
since you know the romans kicked him out
of palestine some even before that so
these are people who have lived in an
urban environment
they know how to engage in long-distance
trade
they know how to deal in like financial
alchemy they know how to
do all you know they know banking they
know law they're all literate at a time
when like one percent of your own
population is literate because that's
what these people do and they don't have
their own
place to live obviously and so they go
from place to place trying to survive
saying what can we do here we can't own
land only the nobility owns land that's
fine
and the peasants work the land but i'll
bet you there's a lot of ways that we
can help out
and they bounced around europe sometimes
accruing too much power too much wealth
and getting run out of their territory
because the king decides he doesn't want
to pay his debts or something like that
but that's how they survived right and
it was fine they fulfilled this
middleman minority rule
for centuries and it was a role that
sort of needed to be filled at a time
when societies were kind of building
themselves up to become more complex and
sophisticated and didn't have that
indigenous capacity but then you get up
to
say the 1800s maybe late 1700s depending
on where you are
and you have all these jews who are
engaged in things like banking
law medicine you know
international trade all of these things
that the nobility didn't want to do
and the peasantry wasn't capable of
doing and they're like we'll just have
the jews do it because
we don't like them anyway they're
outsiders have them do it we get up to
like the 1800s and 1900s
what's every mother telling their kid
that they should go do go be a lawyer
go be a banker go be a doctor and so
they were in prime position that when
society started to change the economy
started to change
they were ready they were ready they had
been doing this stuff for a long time
and they started to become very wealthy
and very prominent and when that when
that started to happen
you got a gigantic spike in
anti-semitism you started seeing pogroms
all over the place
um you have this you have this perfect
storm too where you have like the
nobility elite class
who's turning against them and you also
have the peasantry
that says wait a second these people
have all this money and it doesn't take
very long for the nobility to lead the
peasantry
against the whatever whatever class
we're talking about we could be talking
about the jews we could be talking about
the armenians
100 especially since it redirects any
anger they might have toward the people
in charge
to that layer below them that
intermediary and they would specifically
use them for that purpose
you know they would use these people as
tax collectors they would use them as
estate managers to manage the surfs and
stuff because they knew
that if things got out of hand you know
and the peasants rise up we can be like
yeah you know
we knew that those uh jews were trouble
all along so go ahead go
go nuts and that happened over and over
again throughout european history
and um so so the armenians followed a
similar path this is
so after the janissaries right now we
now is this this mean we now picked up
where we
we killed the janissaries now we need
someone else to kind of
it kind of come in here and run that
round it sort of worked out like that
but the christians had always kind of
been fulfilling those roles
right um the christians in all the
islamic empires if you go back and the
jews as well
um they they're usually urban
populations armenians are a little
different and that's in that respect
we'll talk about in a second but
they were the ones who who naturally
fulfilled those roles the turks they
were the warriors
you know they're not going to go open a
shop yeah you know they're not doing
banking and then you've got a lot of you
know you've got the kurdish tribes
you've got these
a lot of these semi-nomadic arab
villagers and stuff who are out there
the ottoman empire is not we're not
talking about like england in in the
1900s or something
it's a very sophisticated and advanced
society in many ways but you go
like maybe 500 miles out to the east and
it's a wild freaking west down there
you know i mean it is like you got an
armenian village surrounded by
kurdish tribes that raid that village
sometimes and kidnap your daughters and
um you know you go outside the imperial
core and the ottoman empire did not have
the state capacity to really exercise
firm control over all of their lands
it was a tribute empire which is again
reminiscent of the old step
empires like we're not going to come in
and tell you that you got to turn
turkish and you can't speak your
language
just send your taxes and don't you know
have any uprisings and if you do we'll
come and
and you'll learn why the last 10 people
found out that's a bad idea now that was
really how it was it was a tribute
empire
and um the christians and the jews
christians were more numerical than the
jews and so they really
and in the ottoman context when i say
that we're talking mostly about
armenians
in the east greeks in the west and then
assyrians kind of spread out
assyrian christians as well and uh by
the time
a very similar thing they had been
engaging in
these these middleman roles right
administrative
professional and commercial services for
the empire
stuff that the empire couldn't do on its
own things like
most of the biggest mosques that
istanbul is famous for today were all
designed
by armenians armenian architects by the
time you got up to the late 18th early
1900's you've got
the bureaucracy largely in the upper
roles very often filled with
i shouldn't say in the very very upper
roles those are those are ottoman
rulers but all of these sort of middle
management sort of gs14 roles right
those are armenians those are greeks
these you know people like that they
really relied on these people
and it was a similar thing you get up
into the dawn of the modern age
where having bureaucratic skills being
literate and numerate
knowing how to deal with finance and
trade and law and medicine all of these
things that the christians in the
ottoman empire were doing
that's where you needed to be if you
were going to be successful
and they became extraordinarily
successful in the ottoman empire very
very wealthy
um at one point in fact just before the
outbreak of the first world war the most
uh the wealthiest banker in europe was
an ottoman armenian
more wealthy than the rothschilds even
and um when you get to that point
you get you run into that into that
trouble where you have this this
empire where the ruling elites the
turkish elites
are experiencing this sense that
um that they aren't really needed so
much anymore now they don't feel that
they're not going to think that
consciously ever but that's really
what's going on they're in charge now of
an empire
that they couldn't have really built
themselves and they couldn't really run
themselves and
the people who are running it they're
starting to look at
various skew for um a very particular
reason and that was that
this is also the age of european
imperialism
and one of our unraveling episodes
recently we talked about the genocide of
the uyghurs and you go back to the
late 1800s and the uyghurs kind of
became the dominant majority in
xinjiang and that i i got annihilated
from my mispronounced pronunciation of
that word
um what was i saying uh i think you said
no i'm just messing with you um
and uh and the the the uyghurs were in
the territory and they were being kind
of oppressed by this dominant group
there and so the qing chinese said raja
that and they went out and just wiped
those people out they were called the
zungars and they
don't exist anymore and uh really one of
the big drivers for that
was you know we had talked about how in
china outside their borders
or what we think of as their borders
today they never thought about it as
like a hard border back in the day it
was just that was the frontier
past that is the step that's where all
the barbarians live yeah their word for
border literally meant like frontier
yeah yeah and so what they need to do is
just they need to manage the barbarians
out there
it's just one big buffer zone between us
and them well all of a sudden you start
getting
the british empire the french later the
russian empire these other europeans
start coming around in any
territory they see that's not already
incorporated
within the borders of a state that can
actually defend it
they're snatching all that up and so the
chinese say well okay that's not just
the frontier anymore now that's
china and anybody in it has to be
chinese
because if you're anything but that well
then you're somebody you're a wedge that
the british or whoever might be able to
come up and
you know you know driving with bargain
with and
so when these european powers start
picking away
at the periphery of the ottoman empire
and then really starting to close the
walls in
these christian europe obviously uh and
they have a
christian minority population greeks and
armenians and others who
have not been treated particularly well
over the years as a whole
and so they start to worry that these
are potential fifth columnists that
these european powers could use to
start to split off more territory than
they already have so they've already got
that
in their heads um
as we as we roll into world war one
is that is that you know um an
appropriate thing is that appropriate
assessment
oh yeah oh for sure yeah and actually it
existed before that so when you go back
to
you think of like i think you really
have to put yourself in the mindset of
the people running the ottoman empire
and
i think we can actually probably do that
because we're americans right
and so you have to imagine um these are
people who again had
the largest and most powerful empire in
the world for a number of years i mean
they drove
all the way up to vienna twice you go
look at a map of europe everybody out
there and i mean vienna
it's not like there in the balkans it's
up there in central europe i mean
and if they would have if they would
have gotten past vienna i mean
you know germany was just broken into a
bunch of little principalities at the
time and they weren't standing up
ottomans were on good terms with the
french i mean they may they may have
conquered like
you know two-thirds of europe if they
hadn't been stopped by the poles of
vienna
and so you have this empire that's not
only this the largest most powerful
empire in the world for centuries it
controls like its capital is
constantinople the old roman capital
you know it controls access to the black
sea it has
dominance over the entire eastern
mediterranean controls access
between the east and west you know trade
routes
and then all of a sudden you know
starting kind of
really after that 1683 fight at vienna
that they lost it was just a gradual
and then accelerating downhill slide
from there they lose
they start getting chipped away in north
africa eventually they lose all that
they lose egypt the russian empire
finally starts to get its act together
takes over
all of the north caucuses and wars there
the russians are expanding you know you
have
orthodox christians in the balk in the
uh slavic balkans the russian empire is
pushing down there
they lose uh their balkan territories
over time they lose bulgaria
and so you have this empire that is you
know you have to imagine being an
american and it's like
yeah vietnam was tough iraq and
afghanistan were tough
oh no mexico just invaded and took over
new mexico arizona and southern
california and there's nothing we can do
about it
and now cuba took over florida and
there's nothing we can do about it like
the war that's lost it's gone now and
there's this growing sense
that it's not gonna reverse any time
soon if if ever that this is like an
inexorable process of collapse that's
going on
and because it's being done
by these european imperialists or the
ones chipping away at christian europe
um and because of the fact that their
own christian minorities
had been mistreated for centuries
the uh you know there there was this
sort of
sense of hope among some of those
christian minorities that maybe hey
you know we're the armenians over here
in the east it's not great to be
an eastern and ottoman armenian out in
the rural areas in the east
the russian empire they're orthodox
christians there's a bunch of armenians
that live over in the russian empire and
they're actually doing all right they're
not getting massacred
by the tens of thousands they're not
having to pay taxes to
you know the eight kurdish chieftains
that all live around us
and so there was some of this um you
know
these people weren't organized fifth
columnists or anything like that but
there was this sort of sense that things
might be a little bit better if they
weren't living under the ottoman yoke
that wasn't you know completely invented
when uh um after the 1877 war
between the russians and the turks they
lost bulgaria a bunch of
muslim refugees came out of bulgaria and
came and moved into the ottoman empire
they also lost a bunch of their north
caucasian territory and a bunch of
circassian muslims and other
muslim tribes from up there had to be
pushed you know they they they fled
because the cossacks were
harassing them and stuff and so they
start coming down and a lot of them
settled in this area where
armenians had traditionally lived the
whole area of southeastern turkey today
um you know armenia is right across that
eastern border but you go across the
border that whole area of southeastern
turkey where it's mostly kurds today
that that for
many many centuries was all armenians
for the most part that's traditional
like armenia
and um yet all of these others that
moved into this territory
and they started having problems with
the local armenian population right at
this time where
the turkish government is starting to
look at its christian minorities and
specifically the armenians with a great
deal of suspicion
and so you start to get uh
you know you you start to get this this
dynamic where
you know there's multiple things at play
they don't trust the armenian population
out there
and they're mistreating them which is
leading to a certain sense of resentment
from those armenians
toward the government the government
doesn't have the state capacity to go
out there and really like
set up shop and establish order out
there you have all of these destitute
new muslim refugees including a lot of
them are just
tribes or kurdish tribes and things
nomads who
again they're refugees they don't have a
lot going on and so they start robbing
and raiding
the armenian settlements that are out
there and the turkish government either
lacks the will
or the capacity to defend them or to go
out and punish them
and so armenian self-defense movements
start to basically
pop up just so they can defend
themselves from these kurdish raids and
circassian raids
well the turkish government sees that
they say you see they're arming up
they just killed a bunch of muslims from
that kurdish tribe over there we
we knew it we knew they were getting
ready for rebellion
and it was just this vicious cycle that
started to kick into place
to the point where by the time you get
to the 1880s 1890s you mentioned that
song
at the beginning that the turkish school
children were being taught during the
first world war
there was an account i read from an
american missionary that saw in a
turkish classroom
talking like first second third grade
kids and they're going through lessons
where they've got drawings up on the
board
like cartoon drawings of armenians
um including women and children
participating just hacking limbs off of
turks and
you know raping them killing them in
just the most bloody and horrible ways
and these school children are being
taught that this is who these armenians
are this is what they want to do to you
and so this had been by the time you get
to the first world war this kind of
thing had been going on for
for decades and the armenians didn't
have
um you know it didn't come to them as a
complete and total shock
a lot of them anyway because they had
seen a sort of premonition of it in the
1890s
when the sultan abdul hamid ii
infamous and ottoman and armenian
history ordered a series of massacres
starting in 1894 that um
i mean what can you say it was just a it
was a free-for-all total massacre
you know there were soldiers in john
darwin jean-darms who were participating
but really it was a call
on the local populations muslim
villagers and tribes to get out there
and participate
kill your armenian neighbors and it was
specific to the armenians there were
some cases in fact and this happened as
well
in the first world war genocide where
there are telegrams out there and
messages from the government letting
them know hey don't mess with the
catholics make sure that you don't mess
with you know
these others this is about the armenians
and they butchered maybe 200 000
people over the course of about 18
months
and another 100 000 or so died in the
years so after that from starvation and
exposure and whatever and so this is
something where
you know they're not going into cities
and rounding up 20 30 000 people at a
time they're going village to village to
village 50 people here 100 people here
you look at the map
of the massacres in the 1894 midian
massacres
and the whole thing is just covered with
like skulls and crossbones or whatever
symbol they used to say massacre site
massacre site massacre site it's just
all of eastern anatolia was just
covered in blood you know the local
population was basically mobilized to go
out there and kill
your armenian neighbors and that's what
happened
so that's 18 late 1800s and now we start
to get into
i mean is the next major phase when
world war one kicks off and yeah there's
an important uh interlude there like the
the reason that they stopped killing
them you know there's a book that came
out recently called the 30-year genocide
by benny morris and uh george zevi which
is
two israeli historians who looked real
deeply on this and got they probably
went deeper
into the into the records to figure out
exactly moment by moment like what
happened here
than anyone really has and one of the
things that they discovered is that
you know this was not something that
just popped up in the chaos of world war
one
that those massacres in the 1890s
there's only one reason that they
stopped and that was that the british
made them stop
there was uh there was a you know by
this point the ottoman empire was having
huge economic problems
the british and the french were
essentially had the empire's finances in
receivership they were basically
controlling the ottoman
fiscal budget the governmental fiscal
budget they had you know
say so over it anyway and um
in 1896 this armenian militant group
after all of these murders said we have
to do something and there's nothing you
can really do i mean
you know you can't you're talking about
it's not even david and goliath i mean
it's a flea versus goliath they can't
fight back there's nothing like that the
only thing they can hope to do is get
the attention of outside powers who can
wield influence over the ottoman empire
and so they say well what is it we can
do to actually get the attention of
these people what are they what do the
british care about
and so they went and they uh invaded the
ottoman central bank the bank ottoman in
constantinople
and they took a bunch of hostages and
made a bunch of demands
and um the uh you know they they knew
that there were a lot of
european uh hostage hostages that they
would be taking and that there were a
lot of european assets in that bank
and so the sultan at the time he's you
know again these are
these are step warriors these are
hardcore people he said yeah that's nice
your demands that's cool you can throw
them away
and he just surrounded the place with
artillery and got ready to just blow the
place to rubble
and at the same time put out an order
for everybody
in constantinople to just go out and
mask her armenians in constantinople and
that's what they did they rampage
through the streets beating killing
anybody they could find
as he prepared to just blow up this bank
and right at the critical moment the
british
sent some warships into the dardanelles
there and sent a message to the sultan
that if you blow up that bank the next
thing that's going to be destroyed is
your own house
and so they backed down but that's the
only reason those things stopped and he
put an order out that the massacres are
over
and they came to an end um that period
though up until you get to the first
world war most
you know people who look at this
seriously now realize that
the first world war was not a reason
for the armenian genocide it was just
the opportunity for it
this some late 1890s there's actually
you know we can talk about what it was
like we can sort of throw some words on
it but there's probably nothing better
than
going back to the book that we're
talking about armenian
golgotha talking about some of that
stuff that took place
in the 1890s going back to the book
the massacre began on the morning of
december 28th
the governor sent word to non-armenian
christians to assemble in their churches
and not stir
out and refrain from shelting armenians
the troops were then drawn up at the
entrances to the armenian quarter
behind them an armed muslim mob gathered
while the minarets were crowded with
muslims evidently in expectation of some
stirring event
the turkish women too crowded onto the
roofs and slopes of the fortress which
overlook the armenian quarter
the mob was cheered on by the women
who kept up the well-known peculiar
throat noise
used on such occasions by oriental women
to discourage to encourage their braves
at around noon amusing
cried out in the midday prayer as a
glittering glass ornament resembling a
crescent was seen shining from the top
of the fortress overlooking the town
amulla waved a green banner from a tall
minaret overhanging
the other end of town shots were fired
and a trumpet sounded the attack
the soldiers opened their ranks so that
the mob
could pour into the quarter
the governor nazif was seen motioning
the crowd on
the mob guided by troops who had
familiarized themselves with the quarter
during the siege
a body of wood cutters armed with axes
led the way
breaking down the doors soldiers then
rushed inside
and shot the men
a certain chic british diplomat
h fitzmaurice wrote ordered his
followers to bring as many stalwart
young armenians as they could find
to their number of about a hundred they
were thrown down on their backs and held
down by their hands and feet
while the shake with a combination of
fanaticism
cruelty proceeded while reciting verses
of the quran
to cut their throats after the mecca
right of sacrificing sheep
those hiding were dragged out and
butchered
stoned shot and set on fire with
matting saturated with petroleum
women were cut down shielding their
husbands and fathers more armenians were
shot as they scampered along rooftops
trying to escape when the killings
subsided
the houses were looted and torched
as sunset approached the trumpet sounded
again
calling the troops and the mob to
withdraw
the atrocities resumed the following day
december 29th with a trump
a trumpet sound at dawn the largest
number were killed at the armenian
cathedral
where thousands had gathered for
sanctuary the attackers first
fired through the windows into the
church then smashed in the doors
and killed the men clustered on the
ground floor
fits morris relates that as the mob
plundered the church
they mockingly called on christ to prove
himself a greater prophet than muhammad
the turks then shot the shrieking and
terrified massive women children and
some men
in the second floor gallery but gunning
the armenians down
one by one was too tedious so the mob
brought in more petroleum soaked bedding
and set fire to the woodwork and the
staircases leading up to the galleries
for several hours the sickening odor of
roasting flesh
pervaded the town
writing the following march fitzmaurice
noted even today the smell of the
charred remains in the church is
unbearable
a missionary who witnessed the massacres
described the her the horror
as a grand holocaust and for days
afterwards
watched men lugging sacks filled with
bones
and ashes from the cathedral
the trumpet again sounded at 3 30 pm the
time for the muslim
afternoon prayer and the mob withdrew
from the armenian quarter
shortly afterwards fitzmorris wrote
the mufti ali efendi hussein pasha and
other notables
preceded by a band of musicians went
around the quarter
announcing that the massacre was at an
end
and that there would be no more killing
of christians
for the next three days the authorities
employed jews
and donkeys to remove the dead before
the massacres
urfra was home to about twenty thousand
armenians
all told perhaps as many as ten thousand
died over the course of two days
twenty five hundred to three thousand of
them at the cathedral
[Music]
so this was no this was no shocker
moving into um
into world war one yeah although
you know you know there's a there's
there's a maybe a way that um
nothing can prepare you for it even if
you've seen it coming when it happens
you're just not ready there were a lot
of jews in europe in the 1930s who
were writing to their relatives in other
parts of the world saying we got to get
out of here
they're we're sitting on the edge of a
volcano right now who still
when it actually came we're all you know
just
kind of caught with that deer and a
headlights look because what do you do
you know and there's a lot of you can
read a lot of uh
a lot of stuff from holocaust survivors
children and also from zionists who were
in palestine out of the country at the
time who really can't understand like
why are our parents or our cousins who
are in europe at the time like why
aren't they fighting back like why
aren't they rising up or whatever and
it's just you just don't know what it's
like to be
caught where there's nowhere to go the
the enemy's in control and there is yeah
you can you can rush the electrified
fence you can
there you're caught and they and they've
established dominance in a way that
you're not going to
really be able to get out of because
again
these modern scaled genocides like this
are something that could really only be
pulled off by a state
how'd the young turks play into this
yeah so after you
there were there were people within the
turkish hierarchy
who understood that this uh that this
empire as it stands right now
it's got to change gotta make a
transition you have to modernity
if we're going to compete at any level
with
the british empire the rising russian
empire like we gotta get
get it together and the way we're
running things now where we can't even
really control our territory effectively
a few hundred miles out east
that's just not going to do it it's not
going to do it anymore
and so they were modernizers this was a
movement that started out in
universities a lot of medical students
law students things like that
and it was it was an underground group
it was a sort of a revolutionary group
sort of like you were seeing all across
europe at the time you know the
bolsheviks and
a lot of the socialists in russia for
example um
the difference i guess between like them
and the bolsheviks there's a million
differences but the main one is they
weren't international
communists or anything they were fierce
fierce turkish nationalists
but they were they were multicultural
right this was this was a big difference
too this wasn't strictly
armenians or greeks inside of these were
people saying
it's like when you hear today you know
like i'm not a i'm not a
irish-american i'm an american right
these people are saying hey i'm not an
armenian turk or i'm not a jewish jerk
i'm turk
yeah so uh they actually had a what they
called the ottomanist movement
you know they were they wanted um
everybody this is a big thing in the
late 1800s really up until the defeat in
the first world war
that um that ever we're all ottomans
right which at the time was like ottoman
that's just the name
of the turkish commander who like came
in with that you know he
who established their tribe i mean he
was the tribal leader at the time osman
but uh you know by the time you got up
to this point i mean america's
some old italian sailor too right so
like you can do that it's no problem
but there was the idea is that we're all
ottomans ottomans here it doesn't matter
where you were born or whatever in fact
a lot of the young turk and committee of
union in progress which was like a
really militant group subgroup of the
young turks
some of their leaders including some of
the ones that would be in charge of the
empire
during the first world war uh they
weren't turkish
um talat pasha the guy was the interior
minister and the effective head of
government for the ottoman empire
was from bulge he was born in bulgaria
for example and the young turks they had
jews they had uh
armenians the armenians in fact really
supported the young turks at first
because they they thought
we have this force that's maybe more
trying to be a modernizing
influence seems like more of a secular
influence because that was one other
thing i didn't mention is
um as you as the ottoman empire started
to get worried about these
christian societies european societies
pushing up on their borders and maybe
using their inter internal christians
as uh fifth columnist let's create some
divide
they really started pushing that islamic
identity and really playing that angle
of it up which was something they kind
of avoided
before for the most part obviously like
the ottoman empire is the caliphate
right the sultan is the caliph
and so they're in charge this is all
this is you're in somebody else's house
right if you're a christian or a jew
this is the muslims house and everybody
knew that
um but they really they had an empire to
manage they weren't trying to create
problems between their
muslim and christian and jewish subjects
right
by the time when once they started
worrying about the loyalty of these
christian subjects and worrying not only
about that actually worrying about their
non-turkish
imperial subjects like they were worried
about the arabs not wanting to be under
turkish rule and as we saw in world war
one that was a
probably a good call this the british
sent lawrence of arabia down there and
got the arabs to rise up and and march
on
uh on the ottoman empire and so they
wanted to avoid that and so they started
playing up like you know to the arabs
it's
you're muslims this is a muslim empire
how could you side with the british
um they would say to the kurds you know
that you had uh you had the russian
empire who was trying to encourage like
kurdish separatism for example just to
kind of create some chaos and some
problems over there and
they wanted them to say hey you're
muslims don't you see those christians
or just want to destroy the you know the
this this muslim glorious muslim empire
and the side effect of that or maybe it
wasn't a side effect
you know because they were worried about
the loyalty of these internal christians
as well
was that those kurds said yeah we are
muslim and these christians are trying
to destroy this glorious muslim empire
those armenians are christian and you
started to get some real problems there
and when you couple that with like what
they were teaching in classrooms and
stuff by the time you get up
to you know the first world war it's at
a fever pitch
well the young turks they seem to be a
force
and to some degree they were a force
that was trying to move the empire
beyond all that
and so you have these armenians
including like armenian
militant groups you know that had really
formed up because they uh
because of the mistreatment of of the
armenians in the east
who are down with the young turks they
fully support them in 1908 when the
young turks
launch a launch a coup to you know take
over the government they march on
constantinople take over the government
armenians were cheering in the streets
the armenian militant groups were
celebrating that
um in 1909 a year later there was a
counter coup
by the conservative sultan forces the
sultan's forces
and during that brief period that the
sultan was back in power and the young
turks were out of power another 30 000
armenians got massacred in the
province of adana and it was done with
the same character that you just
read you know this is a again
this is the first world war and that
whole period is it's so fascinating
right because
it's it's this war in which
the old world marched into those
trenches and the new world
marched out of them you know it's it's
the pre-modern world and then the modern
world just
really it's that it's that transition
point in that clash
and so you have this genocide that is
done for modern reasons like nationalist
reasons almost right
you didn't you know this idea of like
ethnic purity and needing to have like
our internal peer
that's a modernist idea and the the
means by which it was carried out
administratively and all of these things
the turkish empire was a modern empire
in many ways
but this is a genocide that was not
carried out
uh you know with with ledger sheets and
uh
you know zyklon b and and gas ovens or
anything like that this was something
that was done the old way
it was done with
hatchets and axes and hand knives and
kitchen knives and clubs
and boots and it was something that you
know it was a it was a genocide that was
conducted in in ravines just off the
road and in people's
basements not on battlefields
so the the um situation that we're
looking at
now now we get ready for world war one
and uh the is it a hillary clinton quote
never let a crisis go to waste that was
rahm emanuel
yeah okay president obama's first uh
chief of staff never let a crisis go to
waste
yeah it's a new quote but it's not a new
idea at all oh no
and so world war one breaks out yeah and
this is an opportunity and they get
started right away
and some people who may have been paying
attention at the time
they may have had some idea that the
young turks had
changed a little because they took the
government back over pretty quickly in
1909 so the young turks are in charge
now
and a lot of the armenians feel pretty
good about that at least relative to
what they've been facing before
but in 1910 there was this incident
people were complaining about all of
these stray dogs running around
constantinople
tens of thousands of them that were just
running around they were attacking
people sometimes destroying the city and
the young turk government was called on
to
fix this problem how are you going to
fix it well they sent dog catchers
thousands of dog catchers out
and they caught all of these dogs one by
one it's about 80
000 dogs they caught and they put them
in cages
and they took them all out to this
island right off the coast in the
dardanelles
and they just dropped them off there and
the medium-sized ones ate the small ones
the big ones ate the
medium-sized ones the mean ones ate the
big ones and then the mean ones died of
starvation
and that's how they dealt with the dogs
in constantinople
um you know the young turks were
this force that was supposed to be
fixing all of these old
legacy problems of the empire well they
had a chance to prove it in 1912 and
1913 just the year before the first
world war breaks out
you had the serbs and the montenegrins
and a coalition of other small
balkan slavic peoples up there who
revolted against the empire
and the young turks sent an army up
there and they got pushed back
and the young turks were humiliated by
this they lost the last of their
european
territories and the balkans by doing
that and so
and they blamed very they very much
blamed uh
sort of fifth columnist christians in
those balkan territories for what had
happened and
and right around this time you start to
see the forces within the young turk
movement
that uh is very anti-christian and
specifically anti-armenian because
they're the ones that they really worry
about
the greeks are a separate issue we'll
talk about them a little bit but um
because they killed 300 000 greeks
right around this period too they killed
300 000 assyrian christians they killed
a couple hundred thousand lebanese
christians this was a this was a mass
killing of all christians across the
empire they just
really had it in for the armenians in
particular and so the first world war
breaks out
and you know again i mentioned this like
very near the beginning you have the
armenians who recognize that like this
could be a problem
like this is going to be an issue for us
not necessarily that they're going to do
something like genocide us because
nobody was thinking like that at the
time
you have to remember like nobody had
this was pre-holocaust this was pre-pol
pot this is pre-stalin or any of that
kind of stuff like the idea
that you would have one of these major
empires and and the ottoman empire like
to us maybe
you know we think of it as like this
very sort of exotic
foreign empire that's almost this this
throwback from like an ancient time or
something like that and very orient
this was a the europeans you know they
had were they were fully integrated with
uh with europe for the most part i mean
this was something that
people read about constantinople in the
new york times every day you know this
was uh
people talk about like you know germany
how one of
the crazy things about the holocaust is
like but it's germany how could germany
do something like that you know this is
where leibniz came from it's where you
know gerta came from
and uh you know the turks were not as
foreign the ottoman empire rather was
not as foreign
back then as we probably tend to
otherize it and think about it today
and so nobody was thinking like they're
going to wipe us all out
yeah there might be massacres the local
populations might get out of control and
the local government there might
encourage them or or not stop them from
doing it but nobody was quite
thinking along such totalizing lines
because they just didn't have a
historical precedent for it
yeah the um that idea that you talked
about earlier of sitting there thinking
well
you know this is this isn't going to
happen right how can this happen
well even as it was happening even as it
was happening and it was definitely
happening
let's hear a little bit about what
happened going back to the book
during the first days following my
arrival in constantinople
i hastened to call on several notables
whom i had known for a long time and who
were friends of mine
my general impression was this no one
grasped the gravity
of the situation and no one was worried
about tomorrow
many insisted that turkey would not
enter the war when it began they said
the mobilization was simply a precaution
they were simple-minded people
convinced that as long as the government
was in the hands of the young turks
and talat was the interior minister
no danger faced them
but alas the armenian leaders came to
understand the truth
only when they were already walking on
the road to death
so deceived were they by the flattery of
promises lavished upon them
that when a chief of police and several
policemen came to find anguni
one of the dashnak party leaders
and a brilliant russian armenian writer
and placed him
under arrest the stupefied nguni
am i saying that right agnoony
asked if talot knew about this
and when the police chief showed him the
arrest warrant bearing talat's signature
agnooni was even more stunned and
replied that he had been at talats
for dinner a short while before and
wanted to know why
talot hadn't said anything about it
the unfortunate and agnoony being an
idealistic and honorable man could not
comprehend how talat could plot against
him so cynically
the same talat whom he had sheltered in
order to save talat's life
while risking his own during the
counter-revolution following
march 31 1909 along with
his five comrades agnoonie was taken
from ayash
about four-fifths of the way he realized
that he was going to be murdered
and when vahak the well-known leader of
the dashnox
was warned by his friends in adana
he answered calmly and with deep
conviction
as long as jamel pascha who's the
official in charge of syria and
palestine
is alive no one can touch a hair on my
head
then pointing to a large portrait of
jamal pasha
in a guilt frame prominently displayed
in his room
he said long live my good friend and
friend of the armenians jamal
pasha i recall in detail
the circumstances of the hawks hanging
ordered by jamal pasha
so here you have these people who are
they're looking you know it's like hey
well that guy's a friend of mine he's
not gonna do this to me
one of them you know one of them talking
about um
it's a lot and i already took care of a
lot he's gonna take care of me
or you know jamal pasha he's a friend of
mine
you know there's a um from another book
it's a book that you mentioned earlier
um they have
another interesting thing you know this
is around the time when we start cat we
have we have documents we have documents
that that explain what
what orders were being given and there's
speaking of
talat who was overall in charge of the
government and the architect of the
genocide
one of the documents there's a there was
like a reluctant regional governor
who was kind of kind of playing dumb hey
i'm not really sure what i'm supposed to
do
is this really what you want and talat
sent a
three word telegram
that said yak ver alger
that's it and those those words mean
burn demolish kill
no room for confusion there no room for
confusion there and that's how we
that's how we start moving into this um
this situation just disintegrates now
yeah
so if you look at why the ottoman empire
was brought into the war
by the germans like what did the ottoman
empire
get out of it what did the germans
expect to get out of it what the germans
expected to get out of it
was look they're facing the british the
french and the russians
all three of them have been taking away
territory from the ottoman empire for
years the ottoman empire would like to
take that territory back and these other
three would like to keep it
so if the ottoman empire doesn't have to
help us conquer the world here or
anything if they can just put some
pressure on egypt
put some pressure on the caucuses and on
the balkans then
it's then these other three empires that
the germans are facing are gonna have to
like redirect some resources to defend
them that's the idea
and for the ottoman empire they thought
this is an opportunity to get some
territory back and also to fortify our
position
internally so that uh when this war is
over
we don't have any any problems
inside that can be exploited again later
and um the ottoman empire
was not look the turks can fight they
can still fight to this day from what i
understand i mean they're
they're a warrior people and they carry
that in them but they were not prepared
for this war they weren't prepared to go
toe-to-toe with the british empire
and with the russian empire and so
the first thing that happened you know
you mentioned talat pasha
and you mentioned jamal pasha those were
two out of the three people who were
kind of the ottoman triumvirate during
the first world war
talat was the interior minister and he
was the head of government for all
effective purposes
jamal pasha was the head of the navy and
he was the military governor of
syria which is much bigger territory
than we're talking about today is really
like all of syria lebanon palestine like
kind of that that whole thing
and um he was known by the arabs in
damascus by the way as the butcher
he was uh he starved to death very
similar to the way stalin did the
holodomor
um he starved to death a few hundred
thousand
uh lebanese christians in mount lebanon
where
he was um taking all the food sending it
out to the front
not allowing any food aid or anything
else to come in
and a few hundred thousand people just
starve to death on the streets there are
accounts from people who are there like
american university
um and other western missionaries and
diplomats who say they would
put cotton balls in their ears in their
houses because outside
it was just moaning children moaning
women
people dying on the streets begging for
food it just sounded like the zombie
apocalypse out there just
moans day and night people dying you go
out in the morning and
open up your door and there's a dead
child on your doorstep i mean
mount lebanon lost uh 50 of its
population up there
it was one of the worst hit parts of the
entire country and so those are two of
the guys and the third one
a member of the triumvirate is
enverpasha and pasha is just a term of
respect in the ottoman empire it's a
very high ranking like official
basically
it's not there they're not brothers or
anything and so enver decides
um you know napoleon tried to invade
russia in the winter
hitler is going to try and do it in a
few decades not going to go well for
either of those guys but
screw it let's go for it and so he gets
his force and he tries to go up into the
caucasus
and face the russian army up there maybe
feeling like he's going to catch them
off guard he doesn't
the battle battle of sarah kamish
happens and the russians wipe him out
and push him way back
and so now the ottoman empire is really
starting to panic right if you look at
like when the holocaust really kicked
into gear
it wasn't 1939 it wasn't in 1940
it wasn't even really in early 1941.
it was after the germans got within
seven miles of moscow and then those
siberian troops showed up and pushed the
germans back and they realized this
might not work out the way we thought it
was going to
and they said well what else can we
accomplish then
what else can we accomplish and um you
know because
the caucuses over there if you look at
the territory eastern turkey
you know the armenians in southeastern
and eastern turkey there
right across the border is more
armenians like that's modern armenia
right across the border today and so
and these people didn't you know they
they were separate don't get me wrong
they even spoke really different
dialects you know to a large degree and
stuff but they still knew that those
were their armenian cousins over the
border and they knew it back and forth
kind of like the kurds in
southern turkey and northern syria today
and so
when the russian army pushes past
past that border into eastern turkey
the ottoman empire is thinking with with
some
justice i mean with some reason that
these people who they had just massacred
a few hundred thousand of
a few decades back and have been
allowing to be abused by the kurds and
everybody else who wants a piece
in the decades since that the russians
are going to mobilize these people and
put them to work against the ottoman
empire and so as the turks are
retreating
they are just slaughtering and burning
and destroying
everything they can just terrorizing the
armenians murdering the people they see
especially military-aged men
you know most of the military-age men by
this point have either been conscripted
into the military
and then disarmed
put into a slave labor battalion and by
the time you get up to 1915 around the
battle of gallipoli
uh they'll be worked to death or simply
murdered
the uh generally speaking they would get
these men who the armenians who showed
up for the draft
and uh tell them you're gonna go into
the interior we're gonna build trenches
defensive fortifications and they'd
all go and they'd spend all day digging
a trench and they'd be like great job
can you stand on the edge of it please
and then they would murder them all and
then fill the trench in it was a mass
grave they'd been digging for themselves
the entire time
and so as this is going on you have the
other armenian young men military age
men
um who were like well they either saw
that coming
or maybe they didn't want to leave their
home villages because they were already
getting attacked by kurdish tribes every
other day and they said i can't leave my
wife and kids here and my parents here
and so they just refused to go
but that meant you had to go into hiding
you had to go somewhere because the
turks found you is
a wrap and so all of these villages that
the retreating
ottoman army is coming back through and
just murdering and terrorizing
these are pretty much all women children
and old people and that's going to be a
theme throughout the entire
story is the men are already gone the
men have already been killed a long time
ago or they've had to run away
across the russian uh you know across
the uh
russian battle lines a lot of them did
go join
the russian forces once the uh once the
genocide kicked in
and so a lot of the stuff that we're
going to be that we're going to be
hearing about going forward this is all
stuff that's being done
pretty much entirely to groups of women
children
and old people by by military age you
know
fighters and so that's that first step
disarming and then killing the armenian
uh men who would join the military
happens and the second thing that the
ottoman empire needs to do this is
before the real genocide the mass
deportations and killing really start in
a systematic way
you know they have to lay the groundwork
for it and after disarming the armenian
military people
they decided they needed to get rid of
these two these two towns that they
expected would put up resistance because
they had done so before
they did so during the hamilian masters
in the 1890s in fact
one of them zaitun which was a you know
these are
these are mountain men you know these
are tough people that even other
armenians
kind of looked at them like they were a
little bit crude and uncivilized
they were like uh appalachian
scots-irish kind of like the way we in
america look at like those appalachian
folks like man they're wild and they're
kind of crazy and whatever but
boy like uh you start problems with them
then you're gonna have some problems
yourself like they're not gonna
a very independent-minded um and and
not used to or down with being told what
to do by people
and uh zatun was up in the up in the
hills
and um they knew that they were not
going to just accept this and they had
the capacity
to actually push back a little bit so
that if they started
the mass killing across anatolia at the
time they might have to worry about
these two places either turning into
fortresses where armenians could retreat
and then from there who knows
or just that they could turn out enough
partisan fighters to really create
problems
in uh in the rear echelon and so they go
there first and they just um
they wipe those places out they go to
van von is the second one besides
zeitung
and um you know they go in and uh
give them an ultimatum tell all your men
to come out uh
they do this under under the guise of
like we're looking for draft dodgers and
deserters and so forth and so they show
up
and they just round up anybody who's
there who's important
right any of the older men who are
leaders if there's any
writers or singers or poets if there's
any
anybody who's prominent who could serve
in a leadership capacity
you know as sort of a collecting point
for people a rallying point they take
all them
they torture them and they kill a bunch
of them
and then they give the rest of the
people an opportunity to
turn in any of the men who are still
around or anything and instead the
people in van barricade themselves into
the town
and say we're not coming out give us
back our our notables give us back our
our men our leaders and so uh instead
they roll in artillery
and they just start shelling the town
and um intermittently they'll send in
muslim mobs to go in and massacre the
people who are in there and eventually
they they kill enough people that
they're able to get all the women and
children out and they send them marching
south into the desert
they do something very similar in zatune
as well surround it with artillery
burn down the monastery where a bunch of
the younger men were hiding
and uh then the women and children who
were left there thousands and thousands
20 000 or so in zatun actually um
actually so yeah actually i left out one
other thing this is another thing that
they
that they did to compel people is when
the people in van
uh were holed up and refusing to come
out they said okay roger that and they
just started going to all the villages
around the town and just massacring all
the people there
and um once they had pacified the area
they got all the women children
and old people who were left and they
put them into caravans under guard
and they sent them marching south into
the desert and
this is northern northern syria southern
turkey that's what we're talking about
here so like you have like aleppo and
mosul over in iraq that whole area they
just send them marching south
um and then step three came and this was
really the thing that kicked off
the program now that all of the men with
guns have been neutralized
guys in the military now that these two
potential trouble sites van and zatun
are taken care of
they wanted to make sure that all of the
armenian national level leaders
were neutralized and so all of these men
who are in constantinople and smyrna and
some of the other big cities
including grigorius balakian the priest
whose book we're reading today
were all arrested and deported down
south as well
and they could tell from
the beginning that uh this was something
probably a little bit different than
what they had seen before
well speaking of the book let's get a
little uh
eyewitness account going back to the
book
on the night of saturday april 24th 1915
the armenians of the capital city
exhausted from the easter celebrations
that had come
to an end a few days earlier were
snoring in a calm sleep
meanwhile in the heights of istanbul a
highly secret activity was taking place
in the palatial
central police station groups of
armenians had just been arrested in the
suburbs
and neighborhoods of the capital
blood-colored military buses were now
transporting them to central prison
weeks earlier the constantinople chief
of police had sent
official sealed orders to all guard
houses
with the instruction that they not be
open until the designated day
and that they be carried out with
precision and in secrecy
on this saturday night i along with
eight friends
were transported by a small steamboat
the night smelled of death the sea was
rough
and our hearts were filled with terror
we prisoners were under strict police
guard not allowed to speak to one
another
we had no idea where we were going we
arrived at the central prison
and here behind gigantic walls and large
bolted gates they put us in
a wooden pavilion in the courtyard which
was said by some to have once served as
a school
we sat there quiet and somber on a bare
wooden floor
under the faint light of a flickering
lantern too stunned and confused to make
sense of what was happening
from the deep silence of the night until
morning every few hours
armenians were brought to the prison
and so behind these high walls the
jostling and commotion
increased as the crowd of prisoners
became
denser it was as if
all the prominent armenian fake public
figures assemblymen representatives
revolutionaries editors teachers doctors
pharmacists dentists
merchants bankers and others in the
capital city
had made an appointment to meet in these
dim prison cells
some even appeared in night clothes and
slippers
the more those familiar faces kept
appearing
the more the chatter abated and our
anxiety grew
before long everyone looked solemn our
hearts heavy and full of worry about the
an impending storm
not one of us understood why we had been
arrested
and no one could assess the consequences
as the night's hours slipped by our
distress mounted
except for a few rare stoics we were in
a state of spiritual
anguish terrified of the unknown and
longing for comfort
through till morning new armenian
prisoners arrived and each time we heard
the roar of the military cars
we hurried to the windows to see who
they were the new arrivals
had contemptuous smiles on their faces
but when they saw hundreds of other
well-known armenians old and young
around them
they too sank into fear
we were all searching for answers asking
what all of this meant
and pondering our fate
so these are all of the most famous
armenians in the country
these are the prominent priests the
writers in the big cities these are the
people who everybody in our
everybody every armenian in turkey knew
who these people were they knew them by
name
for the most part and so they wanted to
take them out immediately
and just get them out of circulation at
first
and they did it secretly they did it
quietly on april 24th 1915 which is
armenian genocide remembrance day
because this is where it really kicks
off once they did that
um all most of the pieces were in place
to begin the campaign of mass killing
the only things that remained were um
there was there was this organization
called the special organization that had
actually been set up for a previous war
with the russians but they used it for a
different purpose and augmented it with
different people here um
they freed about some 10 15 000
violent convicts from prisons including
thousands of murderers and rapists
and they freed them and promised them a
pardon if they would
ride with this group called the special
organization which was put under the
command of the most fanatical
anti-armenian young turks
and their job was to
terrorize the armenian population
in an unrestrained manner um you know we
think about genocides you know again
we're very influenced by the holocaust
and the way we think about these things
methodical exactly disciplined
systematic
you know it's like okay what's your
number and check that one off and you
know
and um that's not how this was carried
out
and this this special organization is is
a good illustration of how that is i
mean
you know most genocides when you look at
millions of people dying in
the civil war in the congo or in sudan
you say well how's that happening they
don't have
gas chambers there they're not even
going around and individually
shooting every person that's there you
don't have to do that all you have to do
is go to one village
not just kill them but do it in the most
horrific ways you can possibly imagine
and make sure that a few people get away
to go warn the next village over
and then those people who are mostly
women children and old people because
the men are all
fighting or you know you can't be there
when the army shows up when the militia
shows up
they say we got to get out of here so
they take their kids and their
grandparents and they run off into the
bush
and defenseless women children and old
people die very quickly in the bush well
they die very quickly in the desert too
and so this was part of the goal is to
go out there and terrorize
brutally and make sure that
word of that spreads to the other group
so that these people get moving
because if we can do that they'll finish
themselves off we won't have to go
around
do you know most of the most of the
ottoman soldiers they're off at the
front you know this is being carried out
by older gendarme
uh you know police soldiers ordinary men
type people right like guys like that as
well as by
local villagers and kurdish tribes that
they couldn't have conscripted if they
wanted to
and it was helped along by the level of
just savagery that they would
that they would perform these these
massacres
in and um finally
once everything else was in place uh and
this kind of happened systematically i
guess over the
over the period of time that the
genocide was taking place but the
central government worked to identify
uh governors and mayors of local areas
that might be
reluctant to do what they needed to do
and when they were identified they were
taken out some of them were thrown in
jail and some of them were even killed
but a lot of them were just reassigned
to other places one of them you started
off talking about with a quote about
what happened in ankara
and that was an example actually that
was one where the guy who the the valley
the governor of of that province
he was uh trying to almost be a oscar
schindler type he got together a bunch
of prominent turks in the area had them
write a letter and sign a letter that he
sent back to constantinople saying hey
look whatever's going on anywhere else
like our armenians are actually cool
like we know them they're not a problem
they're loyal
and so that guy was just fired and sent
off to some random spot in the empire
and his his successor came
in and immediately went to work searched
all the armenian homes for weapons
took took them all away right down to
all their kitchen knives
the local jails there were emptied all
the convicts were turned into
paramilitaries
and um once everything was in place they
got to work
you know you think about that if you
were gonna write like a
freaking psycho dystopic
movie right what are you going to do
you're going to take the you're going to
take the the local criminals rapist
murderers and you're going to empower
them and
you know give them give them authority
and total license and in fact encourage
them
to be as brutal as possible because
that's part of the plan you know to
drive these people out into the desert
through through brutality
it ends up looking like this going back
to the book
the prominent prisoners lawyers bankers
merchants and armenian
government effect officials were taken
out on the road in the first caravan
under the supervisor of the police
commissioner the prison warden
police soldiers and officers overall
superintendents was
assigned to shem sedan the son of tabib
a member of the ottoman parliament from
ankara
although those in the caravan were the
distinguished people of the city
a mark was put on their arms and their
feases
shoes and coats were taken from them
before they left the prison
then these 150 so or so were taken out
to the foot of town
and tied together with a rope
the tools that would be used to kill
these armenians axes
cleavers paddles large knives and other
weapons
were transported in four or five
carriages directly behind the caravan
and following them were carriages filled
with lime
to make sure that the crying and
screaming of the people in this caravan
would not be heard
some of the soldiers were ordered to
play trumpets and drums
as they left ankara via the town's
famous
tashcon section
seven hours from the town this dust
covered caravan reached the forest
they were met by the special
organization the freed criminals used as
anti-armenian death squads who possessed
all kinds of weapons
a well-known lawyer
armanak pleaded with the chief of the
bandit group to be given
as the sacred last rite of one condemned
to death
permission to say a few words he
received permission
then he said with unusual
cold-heartedness and a
cavalier indifference to death that
surprised even
even the special organization it is no
longer a secret
that you have brought us here to be
killed
but i want to ask you if you know why
you are going to kill us
the leader of the bandits answered that
he didn't know why
armando continued you should know that
the high ranking officials
and the committee who gave you the
orders to kill us did so solely to
secure their personal gain
and that they are leaving a stain on
your history
and laying waste to the fatherland
barely had he spoke these prophetic
words
when hundreds of the special
organization sheets attached attacked
from all sides cutting and hacking off
legs and arms and necks with axes and
hatchets
ripping them off partly or entirely and
crushing heads with rocks
then the bodies were thrown half alive
dead
or in the throes of death to be prepared
ditches into prepared ditches
and covered with lime
those who were partly sticking out of
the dirt and the lime
made the heavenly arches resound with
their cries of agony
more dirt was poured on them until they
were buried alive
when the massacre of the first caravan
was finished the second caravan
of more than 320 people was sent forward
transported to the park known as kyosh
six hours from town these people were
massacred in the same merciless manner
the dismembered bodies of the martyrs
were left unburied for 15 days
turkish officers then oversaw their
burial by armenian
labor soldiers
after massacring all these people the
special organization came back to town
wearing clothes shoes and other items
they had taken from them
everywhere they boasted about how many
armenians they had killed
and how in unheard of ways they had
tortured and dismembered those who were
still alive
and even mutilated corpses
similar massacres took place in other
towns and villages
with pecu with particular cruelty in
yazgat
first all the armenian males of a town
or city
and then the women and girls were bound
together and taken on a foot
on foot to deep valleys a few hours away
accompanied by a turkish mob
armed with axes
there they were slaughtered like sheep
pregnant women and suckling babes
included
and that's how it went over and over and
over and over it's one of the things
about genocide is
if you ever watch a movie about one or
read a decent book
written about a genocide they'll usually
find some
dramatic persona to focus on so that
they have some kind of drama with it
some storyline or arc to follow because
when you get down to it
what it comes down to is we went to this
village we killed all the men we raped
all the women we robbed all their stuff
took their children as slaves and then
we left
and then we went to the next village and
we raped all the women we killed all the
men we took the children as slaves
robbed all their stuff and we left and
it's that a hundred times a thousand
times
you know you can't tell a holocaust
story or
or write a holocaust book that's just
they marched 10 000 people to the edge
of the mass graves they shot them naked
and they threw them in
and they took these it's just it gets
repetitive in the most
grotesque way imaginable and that's what
a genocide is
the depravity of it is easy to focus on
but in many ways the
especially after it's been going on for
months or years
and the people themselves the killers
themselves have been almost brutalized
psychologically and spiritually by what
they're doing and it becomes routine
for them so that things that some
individuals may have hesitated
to do at first or not things that elicit
any kind of hesitation anymore
that it just becomes this grind of death
and one of the things that makes the
armenian genocide a thing that is
i guess you could maybe only compare it
to what happened in rwanda
in is in so far as the extent to which
the general population was mobilized to
participate
you know um something like again like
with the germans
uh you know this was something ernst
younger during the second world war
was stationed in paris he was sort of a
cultural figure by that point so he was
kind of there as like a
technically was some kind of a minister
of this or that but i can't remember but
really he was there as like a cultural
figure
and um he was in paris 1942
you know 1941 and he's writing letters
to people trying to figure out like i
keep hearing about all these things that
are going on out in poland now in the
east like what's going on out in the
east like i hear about bad things going
on on the east this is earth's younger i
mean this is a guy that even the nazis
like thought this guy was great
you know there was there was possibility
that he was
uh in on one of the um
failed assassination attempts maybe he
knew about it at least but hitler
himself even said nobody touches
ernst younger right this is the guy this
is the guy that wrote storm of steel i
forget which podcast we covered that
that on but i mean this guy is a
a hero to the german people yeah and so
even him
a guy in that position serving as a
minister in paris at the time he's like
trying to find out what's going on in
the east because the way that that was
conducted and you know it gets
overplayed a little bit
how secret it was and everything it did
take a large number of people including
the vermont to pull off some of it
but relatively speaking this was
something that was
able to be kept from the german people
and to be localized to the ss and like
you know the people who were actually
handling it yeah it's one thing to
you know the okay so the german populace
is let's say they're helping round up
jews
but that's what they think they're doing
is rounding up the jews or they're going
to ship them off they're going to be
slave labor they don't
they many cases didn't know the end
state right whereas here we have
the the turkish population at large
doing the tactical operation of genocide
yes and there's a quote from
a great book i know i've brought it up a
few times another podcast uh
um by philip goravich about the rwandan
genocide we wish to inform you that
tomorrow will be killed with our
families and he has a quote in there
when he's talking about
what genocide is and to the society
that's
that's perpetrating it and he has this
line that's always stuck with me says
genocide after all
is a sort of community building exercise
and that stuck with me as i was reading
all the material about
the armenian genocide and the way that
its specific way that it was handled
one of the things that happened was
these people who would be deported down
south
when i say that what i'm talking about
is you know all the men would be killed
and the women children and old people
who were left would be put into a
caravan they'd be sent down to march in
the syrian desert on a march that would
take about two months
and when they got to the end it was just
there was a death camp there where they
would anybody who survived two months
with
you know no food because it would all be
taken from them right away
you know if they couldn't scrounge bugs
out of the desert or eat dead bodies or
whatever they had to do they'd buy
starvation if they couldn't um if you
weren't a woman who could uh
you know use your body or whatever to
get
a turkish soldier to give you a drink of
water or do whatever you had to do then
you died on the way and the roads were
littered with bodies and sometimes they
would just massacre all of you along the
way but the ones who got to the end
would get to these death camps in the
syrian desert
and these uh these routes you know it
doesn't take two months to walk directly
in a straight line from one place
to their end state and place in the
syrian desert they would go on these
winding routes sometimes and it wasn't
just to
drag it out so that people would die of
exposure and starvation they would
actually bring them through
different muslim villages different
territories of kurdish and circassian
tribes
and when they would come through a given
area just like we saw here that people
would be waiting for him with weapons
and they would attack and they would
rape and they would take the women that
they liked away as sex slaves
they would take the children away as
slaves they would rob them of what they
could but it was only
allowed for a certain period of time and
very often the turkish soldiers this is
actually what would happen
much of the time is they would sort of
organize it a little bit and be like
well here's a really really pretty
armenian all of you want her as a sex
slave
well let's hold an auction and then the
turkish soldiers get paid oh well
you know we're going to get a lot of the
most valuable things that they have and
so the turkish soldiers were getting
paid
it was a way of sort of it was a very
crude and brutal
form of wealth redistribution in a way
everything that these armenians had
they were being walked around to these
different villages and territories so
that each of the people in those places
got their cut
and there would be almost you read
accounts where it's almost like
there's a sense of expectancy almost
like a party atmosphere
when people know and other caravans
coming through what are we going to get
this time
and um all of these
these kurdish tribes a lot of these
islamic villages
um there were armenian women and
children uh
tons of them in in a lot of these places
a lot of them would just be taken
sometimes as slaves
and when the novelty wore off after a
few weeks or a few months they would
just be murdered or turned
turned away out in the desert to go to
go wander and die
but then the other thing that's
happening when they're doing that is
that the state is
taking well they're taking the opposite
approach that the nazis took right
which is that they are making all of
these people complicit in this atrocity
that the state is carrying out
it really does bind them together in the
same kind of way that you know
uh you know like in a mafia movie where
you do a hit and all three of us who did
it have to fire a shot into the body
because we're all in this together now
and it's a you know the this shared
knowledge that we have all participated
in this
tremendous crime that even going forward
that can bind people together in a
certain way especially we've all
benefited from it we've taken slaves
from it we've
we've robbed in the maybe the things in
our house right now
the furniture in our house right now
maybe uh
were things that we that we took from
these people when we killed them
and um that's how it went
over and over and over and over again
you know and the thing that always
the thing that is just the most
unbearable to me
is imagining like just i've mentioned it
a few times already but
it's always the thing i can't get out of
my head about this is that these were
all women children and old people the
men were gone already
and just imagining like your mother or
your wife
or your sisters or your kids
being marched along out into the desert
by these people
set upon you know not blown up by a
predator drone
as bad as that is they are being hacked
down with machetes and axes
in in as you saw like in the in in one
of the one i think the ankara example
that you read
in in massacres that would take hours
and hours and hours
it takes a long time some of these
they're killing six seven eight thousand
people at a time
in a ravine by hand and
that takes some time and so it's just
screaming
and the smell of feces and blood
and people you know you have just body
parts hacked up over here
and over there there's just a big rape
orgy and it's all right next to each
other while over here they're searching
your mother's
pockets for any gold coins she might
have and it's and it's that
for as far as you can see there are
times where they did one instance where
they did 6 400
people was uh was the consensus estimate
on it and it was the entire ravine i
mean you come over this ridge and it's
just this entire ravine
hundreds of yards and it is just bodies
and they're not dead of you know this
this place was uh
was witnessed by an american uh from
somebody from the american consulate who
wrote out and saw it afterwards
these bodies are not people who died of
starvation or thirst
or exposure these are people whose are
just one big mass of gashes and
mutilation
and hacked off limbs and women with
their heads cut off
who are laying there with their dresses
thrown up over their head and their legs
spread
with their heads cut off i mean this is
these are the scenes that you see
over and over and over and over and over
to the point where
you know you read a book like the
30-year genocide about it where he
really does take the time to get into
each of the massacres and it becomes
almost sickeningly
nauseatingly boring in a way
and um it's just it's hard to imagine
when you make it personal like that
you know trying to imagine the
helplessness that you would feel
uh knowing that this had happened to
people that you cared about or being one
of those people
it would just it's it's hard to imagine
well we don't necessarily just have to
imagine it we can
listen to an eyewitness a widowed
eyewitness this is going back to the
book
this is transmitted by an american
ambassador to the secretary of state
says this a week before anything was
done to baybord the villages
all around had been emptied and their
inhabitants had become victims
of the gendarmes and martyring bans
three days before the starting of the
armenians
from baybord after a week's prison
imprisonment our bishop had been hanged
with seven other notables after these
hangings seven or eight other notables
were killed in their
own houses for refusing to go out of the
city 70 or
80 other armenians after being beaten in
prison
were taken to the woods and killed the
armenian population of babor was sent
off in three batches i was among the
third batch
my husband died eight years ago leaving
me and my eight-year-old daughter
and my mother extensive possessions so
that we could
so that we were living in comfort since
mobilization began
the marquez com commandant has been
living in my house
free of rent he told me not to go but i
felt i must
share my the fate of my people
i took three horses with me loaded with
provisions
my daughter had some five lira pieces
around her neck and i carried some 20
liras
and four diamond rings on my person all
else that we had was left behind
our party left june 1st 15 gendarmes
going with us the party numbered four or
500 persons
we had got only two hours away from home
when bands of villagers in large numbers
with rifles guns axes etc
surrounded us on the road and robbed us
of all we had
the jean arms took my three horses and
sold them to local muslims pocketing the
money
they took my money and that from my
daughter's neck also all our food
after this they separated the men one by
one and shot them all within six or
seven days
every male above 15 years old
by my side were killed two priests
one of them over 90 years of age
these bands men took all the
good-looking women and carried them off
on their horses
very many women and girls were thus
carried off into the mountains
among them my sister whose one-year-old
baby they threw away
a turk picked it up and carried it off i
know not where
my mother walked till she could walk no
further
and dropped by the roadside on a
mountaintop we found on the road
many of those who had been in previous
sections carried from bayport
some women among them were killed and
their husbands
and sons
we came across some old people little
infants still alive but in a pitiful
condition
having shouted their voices away
we were not allowed to sleep at night in
the villages but lay down outside
under cover of the night indescribable
deeds were committed
by the gendarmes bandsmen and villagers
many of us died from hunger and strokes
others were left by the roadside two
feeble to go on
one morning we saw 50-60 wagons with
about 30 turkish widows whose husbands
had been killed in the war and these
were going to constantinople
one of these women made a sign to one of
the gendarmes to kill a certain armenian
whom she pointed out the jean dharms
asked if she did not wish to kill
him herself at which she said why not
and drawing a revolver from her pocket
shot and killed him
each one of these turkish hanums which
is a
turkish lady had five or six armenian
girls of 10
or under with her boys the turks never
wished to take they killed all
of whatever age
the worst and most unimaginable horrors
were reserved for us
at the banks of the euphrates
the mutilated bodies of women girls and
little children
made everybody shudder
the band's men were doing all sorts of
awful deeds to the women
and girls that were with us whose cries
went up to heaven
at the euphrates the bandsmen and
jean-darms threw into the river all the
remaining children under 15 years old
those that could swim were shot down as
they struggled in the water
after seven days we reached urzingian
not an armenian was left alive there the
turkish women took my daughter
and me to the bath and there showed us
showed us many other women and girls
that it accepted islam
there and and there is the fields and
hillsides were dotted with swollen and
blackened corpses that filled
and fouled the air with their stench
on this road we met six women wearing
the
farage and with children in their arms
but when the gendarmes lifted their
veils they found that they were men in
disguise so they shot them
after 32 days journey
we reached constantinople
one of the things that would happen
on the trail of tears on this on this
road to death
was you know by the time you got a week
out of any of these cities where people
were deported
a lot of the american consulate people
and other diplomats and missionaries who
were there including by the way this is
really worth mentioning they haven't
brought up yet a lot of the people
diplomats who have reported on this and
wrote back
about it and have provided a lot of
material we have today these are german
diplomats
austrian diplomats these are people who
are allied to the ottoman empire in this
war who are writing back about a lot of
these things
there's one memoir that was written
about it by a guy named rafael
de nogales who was a venezuelan
mercenary who was actually serving as a
turkish
as a as a mercenary officer as a major
in the turkish military
and he wrote a lot about it as well um
and one of the things that you that you
hear over and over again is how
by the time you're a week out of the
city all these people are naked
all their clothes have been taken so
they're walking in july or august
maybe in the syrian desert
12 hours a day um or more
you know and they're just blistered up
from the sun they don't have any food
they don't have any water
anything they can scrounge from the
landscape or bag off some
or prostitute from some turkish soldier
or something that's all they got
something maybe they were able to hide
away on their person and so they're
wasting away
naked in the sun and then they would
stop at night
and you'd think maybe they would get
some rest but more often than not the
night time was
the worst time because they would stop
for the evening
and as ever they didn't have tents most
of the time those would all would have
all been taken from them they didn't
have any kind of shelter so they're just
sitting out
in the weather and if there was a
village nearby
or a tribe nearby or sometimes just the
soldiers themselves
this was their time to blow off a little
bit of steam and so they would show up
and they would just be walking through
the encampments of all of these women
and children and elderly people who've
stopped
and they would just take their pick for
rape they would take slaves
sometimes they would just torture um
people
for for entertainment there are stories
of
pretty armenian women being stripped
naked and forced to dance for turkish
soldiers and when they weren't
pleased with their performance they just
doused in the kerosene and watched them
burn to death for their entertainment
there's story after story after story
after story like this
and not a bunch of people from one
caravan we're talking from
all over the country throughout the
entire period of this going on there's
something
you know there's maybe you can get
people to go put a bullet in somebody's
head
for their country you can maybe play uh
play up that angle of it to get them to
do something like that
you've got to really engender a level of
extraordinary
hatred um i think to
to get people to do some of the things
that were being done here
um especially the regular people that
doesn't go so much for the special
organization
you know i think uh i think maybe in in
one of the
unraveling episodes we did i i asked a
question
like if you had a bar in town in any
city in america
where everybody knew that's the bar
where in there there's this room and
there's a person in there and you can
just do whatever you want to them
that's the gimmick at the bar like i
might not go there you guys might not go
there
but i don't think it would be empty i
think it would rarely be empty
and when you're talking about okay what
if you had that in a prison
that would be a lively joint i mean
that's what you had going on here
you had these caravans of women children
and old people
being marched down into the desert very
often by guards who were
from the special organization guys who
were
convicted murderers and rapists who had
been given complete and total license
from their government to do whatever
they want and now you stop at night time
and you're bored you've been on the road
for a week riding in the hot sun on your
horse
guarding these people and
what are you how are you gonna spend
your evening and the way a lot of them
spent it was just
you know again you just it's one of
those things that like
reading a book about it or anything it's
just you really can't do
justice until you really just close your
eyes and try to put yourself in the
position of these people
in the position of a mother who's
already watched two of her children die
of exposure
um and then has her baby
grabbed by a leg and thrown in a river
and then she's gang-raped
and she's going to be gang-raped again
and again and again for the next two
months as she
walks you know this road or until she
can't take it anymore and and commit
suicide basically
um that was the situation
of hundreds of thousands of people being
marched down into the desert like this
well you said story after story after
story
here's some of them going back to the
book and you mentioned
the german diplomats here's a german
diplomat the teachers of the
american school and carper were
gruesomely tortured before they were
killed
two professors had their hair and beards
ripped out
while in prison in order to extort
confessions
and were hung by their hands for days at
a time
another professor went insane when he
was forced to watch
armenians being beaten to death the
governor himself took part in the
torture of another professor
the senior executive president beat him
until he was exhausted
and said whoever loves his religion and
his people
may continue beating
here's another eyewitness who was seven
years old at the time
we heard afterward that together with 17
other armenian young men
they had massacred them by night and had
thrown them under the bridge
thus when we were deported there were no
males left in our family
they took away my five aunts in dur
later they cut the off their heads
impaled their heads
with their bayonets to show them to us
and then
they threw their corpses in the
euphrates
we found only half the body of my
mother's aunt
my mother buried her in the earth here's
a 13 year old eyewitness
the turks came and drove us all out of
the village
they were forcing us to march with whip
strokes they tied our hands behind us
they disrobed us totally and we stood
naked as the day we were born
then they broke one's hand another's arm
still another's leg with axes and
daggers
behind us a little boy whose arm was
broken
was crying and calling for his mother
but the mother had already died
by an axe
they came in the morning assembled us
and started once more to kill and drop
the bodies in the water
below the cave the river kabur was
flowing they caught someone's head
another's leg still another's hand and
all these human parts were piled up
upon one another on the ground
some were not yet dead but had their
bones shattered
and their hands severed some were crying
others squeaking
there was the odor of blood on the hand
and
hunger on the other
people who were still alive started to
eat
the flesh of the dead
one of the effects of this was
a very strange demographic dynamic that
happened in turkey in the years
afterwards there was actually a book
that came out
remember it was in the 2000s or the 90s
when it actually came out it must have
been the 2000s
it was written by a turkish woman living
in con
in istanbul now her grandmother pulled
her aside
when she was very old and told her
her life story and it turned out her
grandmother was an armenian
and she had been taken as a small girl
away we mentioned earlier one of the
armenia one of the turkish women who
were heading back to constantinople with
like a
with a stable of six seven eight little
armenian girls and they were taking them
back to be their house servants and
that's how her grandmother was taken she
was taken
back into a house that was um she ended
up in a place that was pretty civilized
they pretty much just raised her
you know she was kind of a servant but
they didn't abuse her or anything and so
she was raised in this house and
became turkish she remembered who she
was but
everybody thought she was a turk her
granddaughter thought she was a turk and
so
after she told her granddaughter her
life story she wrote the
um she wrote the she wrote the book and
it was kind of a sensation in turkey
because to this day
you know turkey still denies the
genocide and so
i mean it's something that they you know
well we'll talk about that in a little
bit but
that aspect of it the taking of children
and women
the mass enslavement of these people was
it was a huge section
it's almost gosh man
you would almost think that
like it almost seems like a fake worse
than death the people who have killed
your husband your parents your kids
your entire community your entire people
and now they're going to take you
as a slave most of most often when
you're talking about the women they're
being taken away as sex slaves
and very often they're being taken away
not by not that this would make it i
guess any better but they're not being
taken away by some turkish no
notable to go be in his harem and
constantinople they're being taken away
by some some tribesmen
out into his tent in the desert and
that's where she's going to live now
until they get tired of her and
it's maybe not just for him you know a
lot of times these were women who would
be kept
to be shared with friends and company as
like a matter of
hospitality you know this kind of thing
was going on
and you're talking about oh gosh i mean
it's hard to really say but you're
talking tens of thousands at least
of armenian women and children taken
away this way you know maybe 100 maybe
over a hundred thousand
the total number of deaths between one
and 1.5 million
but the number of people who were taken
away as slaves and just kind of melted
into the population or were murdered
later that's what happened to a lot of
these people it was it was in the ten
at least the tens of thousands um
you know sex slavery in the ottoman
empire that this isn't something that
just sort of came out of nowhere because
uh of the chaos that was going on there
was actually
just last night as i was brushing up on
some of this i came across a new york
times article written in 1886
by a journalist who managed to uh
he had a uh he had a guide there in
constantinople that was helping him and
they dressed him up in a beard and
said he looked like you know he was from
the area and he had some money and they
got him into some of these places where
they were selling women and this was in
none of this was going on and they would
they were mostly
there's always christian women usually
you're not you can't enslave muslims
sometimes you know people do what they
do but generally speaking that's what
would happen and so it would be
circassians and slavs and armenians
and sometimes assyrians and greeks um
and so this was something that uh you
know the the sultan himself
the way the sultan reproduced was he had
a harem of hundreds and hundreds of
women and all of them were slaves taken
from christian lands
and they would be kept in a cell in like
a very specific part of the palace and
they would be guarded
by black like black african eunuchs
and so let me just again give you some
idea of like the society we're talking
about here the king has
hundreds of slave women kept in cells
in like his own palace they're not
allowed to interact with anybody else
and they're guarded with
uh they're guarded by eunuchs who were
castrated specifically for the purpose i
mean this is a
it's a different we're not talking about
you know the bundestag or the english
parliament or something
it's just a different different time in
a different place i mean we do have to
remember that
you know um i just mentioned that new
york times article in 1886 that only 21
years before
was when we got rid of you know chatel
slavery in the united states so it was a
different time and there were a lot of
things going on back then
but there's a there's a little bit of
exotic strangeness to something like
that that i think kind of shocks us a
little bit
and this idea that um
you know you could take uh especially
non-islamic women as spoils of war into
sex slavery we saw that
reignite when isis you know rampaged
through everywhere they were taking the
yazidis and everybody else that they
found who wasn't muslim as
sex slaves and it was horrifying to us
but
you know in this part of the world
especially when you get out into the
countryside where things don't change
much
very rapidly
this was something that was not a huge
diversion from
what was normal for people and so once
there was the opportunity it just
happened
at scale and you had tens of thousands
again maybe over a hundred thousand
armenian women and children who just
disappeared into kurdish villages and
into turkish homes set us up for uh
derzor yeah derzor
was one of the main gosh what do you
even call a place like that
you want to call it a death camp but
that sort of makes you think of the nazi
example where this is like a factory of
death and it wasn't
it wasn't that you had these these
caravans that were being wound through
the desert to be robbed and raped and
killed and enslaved as they went
and just eyewitness report after
eyewitness report describes the road on
the way down
is just littered with corpses and body
parts everywhere you go anytime there's
a hill you look over the other side of
it off the road and it's just filled
with bodies back there
the rivers are choked with bodies and
body parts
but some of the people survived some of
the people just figured it out
you just said people who were alive
started to eat the flesh of the dead
people who haven't had anything to eat
for a month
will uh will do you lose your mind when
you start to
when you start to starve and die of
thirst and exposure
and some people made it
and for those who made it
tell was waiting for him you know the
place that they got to
at the end of the line one of them
called derzor
it's basically big open-air cages that
they just pin
people up in and there was no food and
there was no water
and there was no medicine and they just
stayed in there and they died
and now you know this wasn't auschwitz
with
you know double razor wire fences you
know multiple layers deep
people could kind of get there and you
know if you
had an ability to do if you knew
somebody who maybe came down there to
give you a blanket or some food you
might live a little bit longer than
everybody else but people were dying
by the 500 the thousands the 2000s a day
just dying of disease
and exposure and hunger and thirst and
periodically massacre
sometimes when another caravan would get
there and there just simply wasn't any
room for anyone else
they would either take that caravan or
most often they would take people who
were already
degraded near the point of death and
they would be like well we're moving you
to the next location
you're going south again everybody back
on the road and there was nothing south
they just marched them out there people
who were already right on the point of
death they would march them further into
the syrian desert and they would just
wander out there and die
or be massacred the scenes
in der zor that are described or really
something beyond
i mean it's a hieronymous bosch painting
you know
this is from the book
no pen can possibly convey the suffering
and misery
of these exiled armenians persecuted
wanderers
surrounded by savage gangs of police
soldiers riding in thousands of wagons
and carts
and on beasts of burden though most were
on foot
and many of those bare
like dried leaves driven by the wind
they passed through this
soul-bloody passage and onto
the arid deserts of derzor
to die without bread without water
without a shroud
and without a grave
barely had the men from these regions
been separated from the women
and put on the road to exile when they
were mercilessly slaughtered
and their corpses thrown into the rivers
or valleys as food for vultures and
other wild animals
the young brides and virgins were yanked
from the embrace of their crying mothers
and taken to turkish harems
even 10 year old girls were subjected
to all manner of savage unbearable
debauchery
the older women who managed to endure
the terrible hardships of the road
were taken to derzor where they were
brutally slaughtered
during the summer of 1916.
here we encountered two young armenian
engineers
who had been in charge with overseeing
the work of an armenian labor battalion
in tears they told me how in 1915
particularly in september and october
approximately 80 000 armenians of both
sexes
were encamped under tents made from bed
sheets and rags
on the plane near the valley stretching
all the way to the spacious swampy
field by the miami railway station
600 to 700 were dying daily from hunger
thirst and fever when suddenly a lengthy
nocturnal autumn rain came and finished
the task
left unfinished by the human beasts
the people were stuck in the standing
pools of water for several days
severe cold insert ensued and none of
them had adequate shelter
clothing or food
they froze to death by the thousands
falling like the autumn leaves
or they died from dysentery diarrhea
bleeding
and other plagues of overcrowding
the field was soon covered with mounds
of unburied bodies
under makeshift tents entire families
were reduced to corpses
by hunger and cold with no one to bury
them
nor could those armenians who found
their dead kinfolk find any spades
or hoes to bury them with
and behold suddenly one morning to bring
this widespread
and heart trend heart trending
wretchedness
to its ultimate perfection the director
of the exiled caravans and hundreds of
police soldiers
bearing whips and clubs surrounded the
poor people already at death's door
and ordered them to get immediately on
the road it isn't humanly possible to
imagine the hue
and cry the begging and pleading and the
chaos that prevailed in and around those
thousands of tents
the tents were then taken down and the
portable goods and bundles representing
the deportees last bits of property were
assembled
but they had neither carts nor wagons
nor beasts of burden to carry them
the lamentation then began many would
not leave
loved ones who were sick in their death
throws lying on the ground
uncared for and abandoned the dying
aghast
begged not to be abandoned in the open
fields as food for hungry wolfs
and corpse-eating hyenas that prowled
the night
but they had no time to think the
military police
and major and minor officials fell upon
them without pity or human feeling they
struck the hapless
and confused left and right hitting them
everywhere
eyes burst open skulls were crushed
faces were covered with blood
and new wounds were opened up nobody
cared nobody took pity on them
the survivors seeing that they had no
option but to leave
took down and folded thousands of tents
and in an instant
throwing them over their shoulders got
on the road leaving their ill
and dying loved ones behind
the wretched armenian mothers who are
unable to take
their underage children two to six years
old
children who had fallen ill from
starvation extreme cold
and the hardship of the long road half
dead or in the throes of death
had to leave them on top of the already
dead
tearfully the eyewitnesses told us how
two large mounds of corpses of thousands
of armenian children
rose up among them numerous children
who had not yet died and who extended
their small hands searching for their
mothers
the eyes of these emaciated and
neglected angels
bore a look of pleading and protest
directed toward their mothers and
toward god
and from their half-dead lips some of
them cried
that sacred word mommy for the last time
since their mothers could not possibly
take the children along
in a few hours the little ones would be
dead and would have to be left on the
road anyway
it was perhaps better that all of them
the offspring of the same wretched and
persecuted nation
lay down in heaps in one place maybe god
and men
would finally have pity and see that
this was suffering enough
instead of half dead children mothers
carried on their bosoms the weakest and
most exhausted of the children still
alive
until they too had to be abandoned
the angelic souls of thousands of
armenian children
were rising to heaven to tell god of
their beloved mother's
endless sufferings and misfortunes
those remaining in the caravans of
armenian exiles
moved on and disappeared into the
mountains there was an all-encompassing
silence as night came
then the howling and yelping
of hungry wolves jackals and foxes
and occasionally the faint screams of
armenian children
being eaten
for the animals would eat the live ones
first
and that
that wraps up what we're going to cover
from the book and
and of course obviously i only read a
tiny percentage
now to to get the book across to gain
some kind of understanding of
of what took place and
i mean what what can be called
for all practical purposes
is i don't know if this is a
thing to say but this was for the most
part
this was a a successful genocide i mean
it was damn near a
fully successful genocide meaning we got
rid of this group of people
forever yes is is that
i mean there are armenians in other
countries obviously
so the people survived but there are no
armenians in turkey today
and in fact christians in general and
again i don't mean to
dilute the armenian experience here but
it is worth mentioning that this was
something the turks were attacking
christians across the empire at this
period they killed
300 000 assyrian christians they killed
countless lebanese christians and
after the war when ataturk came back and
they were fighting in the west against
the greeks
he killed and then it killed 300 000
greeks
greek christians and then expelled
another million to a million and a half
you know there were three or four
million armenians in
turkey proper before the war started and
when it when it was all over by 1917
really when when the
genocide kind of died down maybe tens of
thousands crawled out of their hiding
places
went from three or four million to maybe
a few tens of thousands
um and you have to call it in a way
successful
because for uh uh you know from one
standpoint
turkey got what it wanted there are no
more christians or armenians
in our country and from
you know from another angle they didn't
really pay for it
some individuals did and we'll get we'll
get to that but
um you know after the one of the
probably the great tragedy of the 20th
century here's another one of its
consequences was the russian revolution
in 1917 the bolshevik the communists
take over russia in 1917 and pull them
out of the war
and so the armenians who have been
hiding behind russian lines
that's where a lot of the armenians in
eastern anatolia retreated just get
behind the russian army here the russian
army packed up and left
they're out of the war and so you have
all of these armenians now
right up into the the what we consider
today armenia proper the republic of
armenia
is wide open it is wide open over there
and there is still a turkish army in the
field that is
um fully prepared to finish the job
and they are driving up into armenia
they're driving toward the capital of
armenia yerevan
we're talking about a turkish army tens
of thousands strong a fully equipped
military force world war one era
military
force and you've got about 1200 armenian
soldiers
and then you've got a bunch of refugees
and older men and everything else who
were given
guns clubs anything that they could find
which is not much
and they're told uh do we flee up into
georgia up further into the soviet union
depending on how bad this gets or
um are we gonna are we gonna make a
stand here
and that's what they did um there were
people
in yerevan lots and lots of refugees so
it was an overcrowded place they had a
lot of people but they only again had
about 1200 trained soldiers
and they were the ones that went and got
everybody organized they rang the bells
of the church bells of yerevan to muster
everybody and you had
women and children running supply lines
everywhere getting everything in place
you had men digging defensive
fortifications you had old men
serving as like signal operators with
flags and things up on
you know up on towers everybody was
participating here
and the turkish army pushed up within
you know just about within visual range
just over the horizon of the capital of
armenia
and they got to a place there were three
areas where they fought but the main one
that
you know people remember today there's a
great big monument there and a great
museum armenian history museum
called sardarabad and um thankfully this
french guy
it's not a it's not a very well-known
battle if you look in general histories
uh they'll talk they'll all talk about
it but they won't get much into the
details thankfully there was this french
guy back in the 70s this historian who
went back
into the records and he got everything i
mean he's a military historian and so i
read that book and
i mean he really gets down to like the
order of battle on both sides and
everything else and i mean you're really
talking about a fully equipped turkish
army against a ragtag
group of refugees led by a few trained
ncos basically
and thankfully they did have some
armenian
russians who once the soviet union
pulled them out of the war they were
like well
you know i'm a colonel in the soviet
army now i guess do i go back
to moscow or wherever they're calling us
or am i going to stay here and fight and
so some of them stayed and helped lead
the effort as well
and this ragtag group put a halt at
sardar about to the turkish advance and
really i mean
there's a historian-american historian
not not armenian but
just a historian of the ottoman empire
who said that
if they had lost that battle then the
word armenia today
would just be a curious historical
footnote you know we'd probably still
have armenians obviously
just like we had jews for a long period
of time when there was no such thing as
israel but that's what we would be
talking about
you know it didn't preserve armenian
independence at the time
they tried you know one of the things
that happened was in that brief period
after they did put a stop to them
georgia armenia and azerbaijan which
were all right there clumped together
none of them
wanted to be part of the soviet union at
the time and they didn't want to be part
of the ottoman empire either so they
formed a little alliance to try to
defend themselves
but as soon as things got a little bit
tricky
georgia was pretty quick to be like you
know what we're going to go at the
soviet union and azerbaijan was very
quick to be like you know what we're
muslims too
and they kind of stabbed the armenians
in the back and attacked them from
behind
and so the armenians then at that point
had to cut a deal with the soviet union
and so armenia became
a soviet socialist republic as well and
so out of the
out of the frying pan and into the fire
there you know
although i mean you know the thing is
one of the one of the things that did
happen in armenia
obviously you know they were under the
same soviet tyranny as everybody else to
some degree but they did understand the
soviets even
as fanatical as they were they
understood to a certain degree that
these people
were not going to give up their national
or religious identity
no matter what we'd have to finish the
job that the turks started if we were
going to
accomplish that and so they really
didn't push that as hard as they did in
some other places which is why
you know to this the armenian church was
able to survive and then to this day
once they achieved their independence
finally
in uh you know when the soviet union
fell everything was in place there
and uh you know say what you want uh um
about the downsides of
i don't know what you would call it of
nationalism or just sort of that
you know um
armenians one of the things that you
find about them and it's something i
love about armenians
really like any mediterranean peoples is
armenians love being armenian
and it makes them it makes them so much
fun you know it's just
to me like armenians in america they're
almost a perfect immigrant group in a
sense where
they are they're they're american 100
you know you can't look at the
kardashians and be like those aren't
americans those are americans
as much as george washington's an
american you know it's just they
fully adopt and like they're down they
join the military they do
everything and fully assimilate and
integrate
and yet they love armenia and they love
the armenian church and they love their
people and their history
and there's no tension there you know
they they're they can be fully patriotic
americans or in france there's a lot of
armenians in france for example
and they never have lost that connection
with uh with their own history
and um in their own traditions and i
think they they really walk that line
really well
um well it's um it's it doesn't have to
be mutually exclusive
to be you know proud of where you're
from they're proof and proud of where
you're from yeah they're proof that it
doesn't
and they didn't um they also didn't
really forget
no they didn't forget you know one of
the things what had happened yeah one of
the things that happened right is
another consequence of the russian
revolution
is you have all of these you know by the
time by the end of the war everybody
knows what was going on in turkey so you
had the british and the americans and
everybody else
who were looking at the ottoman empire
or now it's just the republic of turkey
right this the
the war in turkey went on until 1924.
the brit the british
defeated the ottoman empire they
occupied constantinople but there was
still a large military force
uh commanded by uh a great man and there
was no other way to put it he you know
he was a
he was a hard man he did a lot of bad
things in the field and did what he had
to do for his country i suppose is one
way to look at it but kamal ataturk the
father of the turks
father of the modern turkish republic he
was in command he was in
he was he was a hero at gallipoli the
man who had a fight knew out of command
very smart very tough and he was still
out there and so he moved the capital
from constantinople where the british
had established themselves out to ankara
where it is now
and he kept fighting you know he um at
first was pushing up into the caucuses
to
the idea that if you get past armenia
and georgia
and you keep going northeast there it's
just turkic peoples like
all the way over to western china at
that point so there was this like
pan-turkish idea that maybe okay we lost
all of north africa and whatever
but maybe you know the arabs were always
kind of trouble anyway why were we doing
that maybe this is the empire this
panned turkish empire
the armenians that sardar abad put a
stop to that and then the soviet union
established itself so that wasn't going
to work out
and so they retreated back and
eventually they went back and
pushed everybody else out of their
country and established the modern
republic of turkey
and kamalada turk was he was a young
turk he was a member of the young turks
he had broken with the triumvirate a
little bit
over over you know military reasons over
the years but he was still part of these
people and a lot of the young turks and
even the committee of union in progress
the core group that was really carrying
all this out they were still there they
were still
in the government you know there was no
real we had denotification after the
second world war
and there was really not a whole lot of
that going on some of the very very main
people
you know they fled they uh fled the
country
and so this wasn't carried out but they
were tried and absentia some of them
were sentenced to death some of the main
architects
um but after a little while everybody
realized that turkey is going to be kind
of strategically
important now that we have this huge
threat of the soviet union looming up
here
and so like it or not we're going to
have to kind of
find a way to like bring turkey back
into the fold i mean turkey was in nato
by the 1950s
and it was considered a strategic
necessity to just kind of
forget about all this you get all the
way up to the 1980s
and there was a um an american scholar
named susan blair who found
a bunch of the american consulate
documents
that people had people didn't even know
about these yet you know because nobody
was studying this it was not something
that people really wanted to look into
because turkey
we have nuclear weapons in turkeys is a
supremely important ally in the cold war
nobody wants to look at this
and so in the 1980s susan blair finds
all these documents by people like
leslie davis describing everything that
they've seen out there and she says well
this is incredible
writes it up as a book tries to get it
published she can't get it published
anywhere
she's told by major publishers that this
is too controversial
we can't touch this and the thing is
those people were right
because she finally found a publisher
and that publisher started getting bomb
threats
they started getting death threats she
and her family had to go into hiding for
a while
because the turkish government
they don't play around like um have you
seen that movie the promise
no it's it's a great movie it's about
the armenian genocide and it's a really
really good movie
but you wouldn't know that maybe this
has changed a little bit now you
wouldn't know that by going on like
rotten tomatoes
the first night or first day that that
thing was released
there were like 5 000 like one star
terrible horrible worst movie ever
reviews
and like all of them had kind of broken
english and like whatever else i mean
you see that and then immediately
afterwards
literally like the next year there was
another armenian genocide movie that was
put out that was sponsored by the
turkish government and it was just
it's almost worth watching for just the
the madness of the propaganda i mean you
really have to like imagine a movie
about
the nazis and the holocaust where all of
the ss officers and heinrich himmler and
everybody else are just portrayed as
like
they're just really trying to help all
these jews but like
the jews they just they ran off out
there into poland and something happened
to him and i mean it's that bad
you know it's really that bad and it is
like a state effort
ever since then um you know it was
happening at the time they were they
a lot of this was carried out with burn
after reading telegrams and things like
that some of them were preserved but
um throughout the 20th century all the
way up to the present day there's turks
still going through all the archives and
going through it being like
shred that shred that they've been doing
it for centuries and it's because they i
mean look
um this is this is maybe one of the
darker things to point out about it is
they know
they know that that can work you know
people forget things
people forget everything it doesn't
matter what you did or
how bad it was or how many people were
affected
they have this idea that if you just
keep denying it
keep calling everybody a liar keep just
do whatever you got to do that give it a
century
all we have to do is survive you know
if you if you look like this was
something that was really prominent at
the time right you re
all the re the writings of lenin for
example
and trotsky and stalin you know all the
bolsheviks and you see the same strain
in hitler
where they all understood that we're
about to do something that is
horrific and barbaric and that is going
to be condemned by everyone
uh and we better not lose this war
but if we don't if we pull it off then
all we have to do is survive
and then wait it out and the storm will
pass
and um it passed very quickly like i
said
hitler was partly inspired by you know
the
the armenian example specifically
because even by then
just 30 years later 25 years later at
that point when it got started
even by then he could say and make a
good point with it
who today remembers the armenians this
is 25 years after
uh his own country was allied to the
ottoman empire as it executed
one of the most thorough and complete
genocides in history
[Applause]
well you can say there was some
level of vengeance on it and um
we're not going to talk about that now
uh but we are going to
talk about operation nemesis
on the unraveling podcast which we also
do
it's a little take things a little bit
different and a little bit deeper
and we'll do that we'll talk about
operation nemesis well you can
listen to it right now it's um jocko
unraveling podcast where
daryl and i are going to go deep well
we're going to go deep on
on this operation that carried out it
was uh what would you call it a
a campaign of assassination that's
exactly what it was and
and it was done by a bunch of armenians
without any state support
you know if you think about everybody
looks looks at like what the mossad did
the israelis did after
the second world war they hunted down a
thousand fifteen hundred nazi officers
ss
officers around the world and that's you
know
that's that's good for them but the
armenians you had a group of people who
were doing this completely independently
without any state support this group of
hardcore militants who hunted these
people down
all around the world and essentially
took out the entire
ottoman government that was running this
during during the period
all the high-ranking people there is one
other thing i want to close with i kind
of forgot about earlier
because there is uh on the whole
question of turkish denialism
um this is a quote from a letter
written by the leader of the special
organization a guy named bahadin shakir
and this was a letter that was found
fairly uh fairly recently last few
decades um
this is right near the beginning of it
he said the committee of union in
progress
as the bearer of the nation's honor has
decided to free the homeland from the
inordinate ambitions of this accursed
nation and to assume the responsibility
for the blemish that will stain ottoman
history in this regard
the committee which cannot forget the
country's bitter and unhappy history and
whose cup runneth over with unrelenting
desire for revenge
has decided to annihilate all armenians
living within turkey
not to allow a single one to remain and
has given the government broad authority
in this regard
on the question of how this killing and
massacring will be carried out
the central government will give the
necessary instructions to the provincial
governors and army commanders
all of the unionist regional
representatives would concern themselves
with following up on the matter
in all of the places where they were
found and would ensure that not a single
armenian would receive protection
or assistance not a lot of room for
doubt there
evil
with that um echo charles
maybe we could do a little decompression
old-school decompression
scenario that was a rough one
yeah i don't i'm not sure that i can do
that right
this moment but jeez man it kind of hard
to
listen to all that and then even that
last part and then be like yeah
by the way yeah yeah let's all start you
know get back to lifting weights and
drinking well if you remember like i
think the very first time
i actually needed to decompress i want
to say it was
podcast number 12. didn't take long it
didn't take long but after podcast
number 12
where we were um we're talking about the
the highlander in prison and
you know he's getting tortured by the
japanese he's having
um the the maggots eat the gangrene
flesh off of his legs in order to
survive
he's gets put to a medical camp
eventually gets put out to sea
while he's you know um you know the hull
of a ship with
however many hundreds of prisoners
[ __ ] all over themselves
and in their own urine and sweating and
starving to death and dying and then
they get hit by a because the because
the japanese didn't mark their prison
ships
so they get hit by a torpedo and
most of the guys die but he somehow gets
thankfully recovered oh but
but recovered by a japanese ship and so
then from his japanese
ship he gets taken back to shore and he
is stationed
in a prison camp in the outskirts of
hiroshima so that was the first time
when i got done reading some of his you
know some of that
book um you know i said uh
echo you talk for a little while why i
freaking decompress
so world can be a horrible place
and the best thing we can do is maybe
make our little part of the world
a little bit better what do you got for
suggestions well
let's start with ourself mentally and
physically hopefully
um don't forget i give you a hard time
about your job being
super easy yeah this is one time you got
to earn you know earning challenges
for sure challenges rough transitions
yeah
well either way we want to keep
ourselves together mentally fit
speaking of which daryl cooper uh always
impressive with
how deep you can just sort of just go
thought you were talking about it
well you know they're guns i you have
little ways to go which is cool
you know and i'm very supportive of it
and you know either way
we are working out we're reading not as
much as derek why don't you tell me what
i can do to maybe uh to maybe catch up
okay well you could have get some look
at this he's got skills on the
transition as well
very good skills on the transition uh
either
yes we're working out we're reading
we're doing all this good stuff for
ourselves so we can provide
good stuff for others and make our
little world a better place and
it spreads before you know it hey we've
got a better place we're all living in
i'm
in full support of this so while we're
working out we might need some
supplementation
probably it helps big time helps all
right let's start with
discipline go all right mental and
physical
uh support we'll say
and we have essentially an energy drink
you don't like it still it's hard to say
that bro good because here's the deal
when you say essentially an energy drink
what are we thinking the stigma
we're thinking stigma we're thinking
well it's not just a stigma it's a
reality yes reality
is you say energy drink you're talking
about high sugar content ridiculous
caffeine a bunch of chemicals to
preserve the whole scenario
we're talking we're not talking energy
we're talking poison yeah that is the
association for sure
so well we're not talking about that so
we're not talking about that in fact
i don't think we're ever gonna be
talking about well technically we're
talking about it but
when i'm talking about discipline go the
rtd
ready to drink can of
quote-unquote essentially an energy
drink this is what i'm talking about
no chemicals no sugar no
tastes good and it's good for you
you drink two of these you know how
people uh you know we have friends i
don't want to name
any names tim ford he used to be might
still be i don't know
but they'll get addicted to like energy
drinks they'll get addicted to them
meanwhile with that addiction you're
getting less healthy less you know like
you know when you drink
three of them you're like man that
probably isn't jamming my health up
this is probably no it's straight up is
straight up yeah but this one you drink
three of them guess what
you're healthier so go get addicted if
you want get addicted to something good
for you it's like getting addicted to
carrots you can't eat too many carrots
i know that's bad i know that i actually
learned that one time i
ate a whole like bag of carrots and then
realized and i i
you know whatever it was three hours
later i was googling can you eat too
many carrots
and google said yeah your body can't
digest
too many carrots and so guess what your
body does
it's not pretty don't eat too many
carrots but you can't
drink a lot of discipline go yeah and
not to go too deep into the too much of
a good thing
concept but even technically the most
vital
nutrient if you want to call it water
you can drink too much water yeah it's
called drowning die
no no i think that's when you inhale
water yeah the best thing about the go
energy drinks is i was one of those
douche bags
i was pounding like 300 milligrams of
caffeine i came in here one time with
one of those things and chuck was like
what are you drinking
ugh what are you doing to yourself and
so i switched over a while back
and here's where i was worried like i
always thought that i needed a huge
amount of caffeine i'd drink one of
those 300 milligram things and after
like an
hour i was just dead again i was like i
guess i need 600 milligrams
wrong i guess i need coconuts it's the
opposite of the truth because i actually
switched over to these things which are
what like 95
i think milligrams and i only need one
of them and i hit one of those things
and it's good
maybe i'll drink another one if i got
something to do in the evening but
that's it there's a bunch of things that
counter that caffeine
you know when you've got sugar in there
it's like okay cool you're going to get
an insulin hit you're going to bring you
back down
plus we've got thermo bromine in here
things that that
help that caffeine in go
helps it kick so you don't need to od on
it
yeah no need um hey we also got joint
warfare
for your joints we got krill oil for
your
overall general goodness yeah overall
just general goodness of the world
get yourself some krill oil we got
discipline go in a powder form
yeah by the way the the jocko palmer the
iced tea combination
i think on both i think on everything
it's the best but that's what i like
i was mixing that up and that's a
freaking good tasty little treat too
pre-jiu-jitsu scenario
protein protein like that chocolate
peanut butter are you down with us is
that your go-to hell yeah
are we doing the dakota meyer technique
making pudding
or whatever the thing have we done that
yet yeah yeah i mean what was the rest
i think it's just like less milk or
whatever but i think he put it in
something like
peanut butter or something no i'm gonna
have to
you can make all kinds of tasty things
with milk it's true or you can just have
milk as is
yeah which is also a tasty thing the
peanut butter milk is a peanut butter
is freaking delicious that thing is
delicious
oh yeah i would drink it just like as a
normal treat
normal dessert yeah that's for sure
that's the dichotomy of molk
the dichotomy of molk is you're like i
want something good for me but i also
want to taste something delicious i
think
i think we have a title for the episode
yeah that might be the next book
uh so we got warrior kid stuff we got
tea
and by the way this stuff you can get
the drinks at
at wawa east coast east coast all east
coast wawa go in there
clear some shelves support the cause
vitamin shop you can get all the
supplements at vitamin shopping we got a
bunch of other
uh retail that we'll be rolling out in
the near future
and and listen any of this stuff if you
go to jackoffuel.com
we'll ship it to you for free if you get
a subscription because
let's face it we know that there's other
elements out there that are providing
you
with free shipping and we know that
that's kind of cool that's a good thing
we don't we're not taking anything away
from that but we have to at least match
that
right we have to at least level the
playing field a little bit how do we do
that
free shipping free shipping if you get a
subscription to any of these things
which is
good for you in two ways number one you
save the shipping cost number two
you're not waking up one morning you're
out of mulk what are you having for
dessert then
oh oh you go to go get a milkshake cool
can i have a milkshake and some type 2
diabetes up in here
uh jackalfuel.com check it out
what else we got originally origin
origin usa
dot com american made stuff and
for real american made not imported
and then sewn and then they sew that the
tag on
yeah in wherever you know no no groan
and sewn it's true so origin usa we've
got jeans
boots boots jiu-jitsu stuff geese
have you put on your rift ghee lately
yeah that thing is
ridiculous left in it last night you
don't have one yet dude
dude when you this is not it's sort of
like
it's sort of like what energy drinks
what go is to energy drinks
rift geese is to geese it's that
freaking hype
good analogy you're so frustrated if you
ever have to put on a normal gee again
you'll be mad
literally you'll be mad literally yeah
that actually happened to me i was like
i'm kind of mad right now you don't want
none of that
uh geez rash guards joggers
if you're a jogger type human which echo
trolls happens to be
i go in and out for sure well yeah a lot
of good stuff all american media or
origin usa dot com also draco has a
store
discipline equals freedom shirts
hats hoodies okay won't you just break
into the
scenario we have the the unfortunate
scenario that we have right
i didn't find it as unfortunate as maybe
maybe you did
well of course not because you took care
of yourself
you gotta look out for number one you
took care of yourself so of course
you're happy
well okay you're over here got you got a
cool shirt that i don't have i
incidentally
halfway took care of myself and it just
kind of came to light
check in your attention so okay so we
got this thing okay on jocko store you
click on the shirt locker
s-h-u-r-t locker creative
wait you made it up okay very creative
what i'm saying creative creative
yeah so sure actually i didn't make up
somebody on twitter oh yeah
instagram someone told me call it the
shirt locker i was like damn
fully approved anyway so it's a it's a
subscription
situation for shirts creative designs
you had a question mark i feel like
there was a question mark in your head
about like oh what are the creative
designs yeah i don't know what that
means but
they look cool and now you just were
wearing the other day on the mats of
justice
and i don't have it and then you explain
that i can no longer get it
so anyways if you want to get cool
shirts you don't want to miss out yeah
so and and that
actually when you kind of explained it a
little bit i was like yeah that is kind
of a thing
it's because it's hard to communicate
like hey these shirts are going to be
like cool
maybe not what you're used to all the
time but they will be cool to have
whatever maybe that's an indication that
people don't really trust
your assessment of what's cool what's
not be that as it may the facts are
these
it's hard to be like hey guys get this
they're going to be cool and then that's
sort of it
maybe it's just your personality that
you like me i think we have the
similarity we don't like sitting here
saying like hey
i'm making something and it's going to
be cool yeah so that would be whack
that makes sense yeah so i'm going to
say echo's been making some stuff and
it's cool
and if you want to get it then you got
to go get that shirt locker on including
myself because apparently
even if a cool shirt gets made that
actually says discipline and freedom on
it
i don't get a version i don't get a pair
us uh
uh what is it a copy a copy issue
an issue i don't get issued nothing okay
so well this this was the thing from the
beginning if you remember
shirt locker you get you get a shirt
that month and it's gone you don't we
don't sell them on the store
that's why you sign up for the shirt
locker so you can get them yeah
every month yeah so you can't come to me
after everyone's already arrived and be
like where's mine
it's like well again i think we we have
to take some we just can't blame
everyone we have to take
ownership and be like hey the ownership
is
we have failed to convey the level of
coolness of the shirts that are coming
so if you want to
if you want some get your shirt locker
on yeah that's about that
it's true also don't forget about the
just the your everyday
representing on the path it's not an
easy path
no but if you're representing let's face
it
it makes that path a little bit more
i don't know a little bit more something
enjoyable yeah it's true hey
subscribe to this podcast if you want to
um also we have some other podcasts we
have the jocko
unraveling and the jocko unraveling
podcast
daryl and i go deep on some stuff we're
actually going deep on operation nemesis
so if you want to check that out
look up jocko unraveling what's up the
grounded podcast got the warrior kid
podcast and daryl has
his podcast which is called
murder made and you can join us on the
underground
where we're putting out we're putting
out
more podcasts how is that even possible
we're putting out more podcast giaco
underground
listen there's there's strange things
happening in the
podcast world in the whole world
censorship
um random people being pulled off of
platforms
we don't know what's gonna happen and we
would be stupid not to have some kind of
contingency plan so we have a
contingency plan
of if we need to we don't want to but if
we need to
we can survive some kind of a traumatic
platform event where if they want to
start
putting adverts injecting advertisements
into this podcast or whatever
we don't want to have that happen so we
need to have an alternative platform
we're building it
we don't want to take sponsors and have
people you know
have to do reads i don't want to do that
so if you want to help us not do that
and you want to help us have a
contingency ready
then uh you can you can subscribe to
jocko underground
jockonunderground.com could you imagine
giaco doing some basic ass read for like
a mattress company oh my god
it would be in my nightmares or it might
even sound
i mean not to me it won't sound awesome
but it would be like one of the better
reads you've encountered
we're not doing that okay we're not
doing that all right there you go i've
been lying in bed for three hours
i can't sleep what can i do
you know but there's some good stuff on
there though recently
daryl cooper's been uh gracing us with
his presence but yeah about the
psychology stuff
well that's a cool thing it's an
opportunity to talk about things that
are
just outside the purview of actual jocko
podcast
speaking of which i got some good topics
coming up on that one i got some good i
got some good things we're going to go
we're going to go on it's got that
mischievous look
yeah good yes also
youtube we have a youtube channel
official we do have a youtube channel if
you want to see the videos
that i am the assistant director on then
you can watch them and if you like them
those are the ones i was the assistant
director on
otherwise echo is in charge well you
know me and carrie we got some stuff
cooking so you know
cool maybe we'll allow you to assistant
i assume it's i assume it's in this slow
cooker as usual uh
psychological warfare i made an album
telling echo
how to overcome his moments of weakness
and he recorded it and now
you you can listen to it psychological
warfare you people ask me for alarm
clock
yeah you can just get that and you can
put it as your alarm that's why we did
it
mp3 check that out wherever you get your
mp3s
um flip side canvas dakota meyer down
there making american-made stuff to hang
on your wall
keep you on the path got a bunch of
books obviously you can go to
jockopodcast.com
books and you can order books from the
podcast is this one
i don't know if you're gonna be able to
order this one i i had this one in my
collection
um it's a used copy i don't know if it's
still available
but it's armenian golgotha
you can try and get we'll see if we get
if it's available we'll get it up there
final spin i wrote a book
that is a fiction book i can't
novel to me just doesn't sound cool
does it sound cool to you no even
especially if i was like i wrote a novel
that sounds weird right yeah it doesn't
match it doesn't match it doesn't fit in
yeah so i need to come up with another
word maybe i'll come up with another
word like mok
but for like something that's kick-ass
that's not true
that's a story and then i can be like oh
i wrote up
whatever that thing is okay and that way
i can still
you know feel feel good about it yeah
that's a good idea
because i don't it's just not my thing
like i wrote a novel yeah i mean
like technically what's the technical
definition of a novel
there dc oh if you start wanting to
differentiate it between
a novella and a novel it gets very hairy
sometimes
maybe let's say 100 pages i think it's
pretty i think it's pretty well you're
talking about the difference
between extreme ownership yeah no yeah
i'm talking about i'm talking about
what's a novel
yes that's like a category have you ever
what's a cool novel that you've read or
you've read
blood meridian okay that's the only cool
not well
um maybe there's some other ones but
yeah blood do you call blood meridian a
novel
yeah okay then i guess i'm down with it
kind of because blood meridians yeah but
then the next step is to call yourself a
novelist
are you ready for that because that's a
good that's a good point i wrote a novel
right in line with freaking blood
meridian novelist
who wrote a novel the the story is
called final spin
it's available for pre-order right now
the look the publisher's thinking
who's going to buy a book by this
knuckle dragger
we're going to we're going to show them
who's going to buy a book by this
knuckle driver leadership strategy and
tactics field manual
we got the code the evaluation protocol
displays freedom field manual brand new
versions out
way the warrior kid four three two and
one mikey and the dragons
talked about that a little bit with
jordan peterson the other day
about face by hackworth i wrote the
forward for the new version and the old
school
og extreme ownership and the dichotomy
of leadership
echelon front i have a leadership
consultancy we solve problems through
leadership you can go to
echelonfront.com
for details on that ef online revamped
it's online leadership training it's
outstanding i'm on there live
all the time interacting if you want to
come and ask me a question go there
muster 2021 listen we are executing
it's in full execution mode there's no
stopping this train
may 25th and 26th in orlando if you want
to go
go immediately to extreme ownership dot
com
because now that people realize we're in
go mode it's going to sell out
so if you want to go may 25th and 26th
come come and get it man it's two days
it's
it is granular and it is the pragmatic
leadership skills that you are going to
take from that
event bring them back and it's going to
have an impact in your world
so orlando may 25th and 26th phoenix
august 17th and 18th and vegas
october 28th and 29th ef battlefield
pay attention for those in the future
i'll let you know when the next one is
scheduled
um they're outstanding and we do them
at various battlefields and if you want
to help service members
active and retired you want to help with
their families gold star families check
out mark lee's mom
mama lee she's got a charity
organization and if you want to donate
or you want to get involved
go to americasmightywarriors.org
and if you want more of my wretched
reading
or you need more of echo's irritating
inquiries
or you you just you just want to hear
more of daryl's
pedantic postulations
you can find us on the interwebs the
novelist coming out there yeah there you
go
on twitter on instagram the gram
and on facebook echo is at echo charles
daryl is at martyr maid
and i am at jocko willink and as you
heard in this episode
there is evil in the world and there are
those people
that stand up against evil
and some of those people many of those
people
are our military service men and women
out there around the world
fighting to keep evil at bay and at home
are police and law enforcement
firefighters and paramedics and emts and
dispatchers and correctional officers
and border patrol and secret service and
all the first responders
all out there doing the same thing so
thanks to all of you
out there in uniform protecting us
and everyone else remember this evil
does
exist and it's out there
it's a mob it is a
frenzy it is pent up
frustration and anger it is jealousy
and it is envy and it is resentment and
it is out there
and it is also in all of us
and it is up to all of us to fight it
so keep on fighting
and until next time this is daryl and
echo and jocko
out